foreign
the first witness this morning is is
Roger Hargreaves peace
God the evidence I shall give that the
evidence I shall give shall be the truth
shall be the truth the whole truth the
whole truth
nothing but the truth
could you commence please by giving the
inquiry your name please uh my name is
Roger Hargreaves
Mr Hargreaves thank you for your
assistance
in this inquiry and for the provision of
the multiple witness statements which
you've provided
um I think all of them known as
corporate statements because you've been
good enough
to making choirs on behalf of the
governmental Department in which you
work
to to set out for the inquiry
the much of the history and the
chronology of
Britain's approach to preparedness
so thank you for that have you provided
three witness statements
we won't go to them all in in detail
each one has been signed by you
together with a declaration as to the
statement of Truth
Milady may always be published certainly
and they're dated February 1st of
February 23 the 28th of April 23 and the
26th of May 23.
please whilst you give evidence Mr
Hoggers would you keep your voice up so
that we may hear what you have to say of
course and that your account is recorded
for the stenographer
if I asked you a question which is not
clear don't hesitate to ask me to repeat
it we we may get to the break with your
evidence in which case there will be a
break uh mid-morning
I'd like to comment if I may about
asking you some questions about your
role
you are currently
uh are you not the director of the Cobra
the cabinet office briefing room unit
which is a directorate within the
cabinet office yes that's correct and is
that a role that you've held in fact
since July of last year 2022 yes before
that were you the director of the Civil
contingency Secretariat of which we've
heard much
and was that a post that you had held
since October 2020 that is correct and
so does it follow that you took over the
role of director of the Civil
contingency secretary from Catherine
Hammond from whom a lady had last week
yes there was a an interregular of about
four months but uh yes
following
your appointment as the Director of the
Civil contingencies Secretariat
the Secretariat was
split was it not and it was split into
two parts
firstly
and it appears to be a more specific or
a more precise entity the Cobra unit the
cabin office briefing room unit and
secondly the resilience directorate
which was then a new directorate formed
within the cabinet office
general terms why
and
plainly it was post uh posted these the
the commencement of the covid pandemic
why was that split affected why was that
done
I think the simple headline would be
when you've got an organization that
does planning and response there is
always a risk that
the response phase draws you in
and therefore people who are engaged in
longer term planning are disrupted to an
extent and that I think had been a bit
of the history of the Civil contingency
Secretariat that had happened over time
um you know this is the third my third
stint in this bit of
uh the cabinet office and that
experienced it previously is kind of
ever since the formation of the
organization that has some benefits you
can draw stuff across and it means that
people are thinking about planning have
a real understanding of what actual
response feels like why they're doing
their work
but that separation of responsibility
that sort of specialization was the
rationale behind it maybe just look for
a moment at that in in more detail so
your evidence is is it that
because
part of the functions of what was then
the Civil contingency Secretariat
involved
the the maintenance the running the
operation of the United Kingdom's
actual crisis management capability the
Cobra room the facilities the
Secretariat around it the provision of
advice the running of our crisis
management system
alongside the general policy work and
the supervisory work and the
coordination liaison that was a
necessary part of being responsible for
the whole civil contingencies structure
it was sensible to split out that crisis
management capacity out of the Civil
contingency secretary is that correct
yeah I mean to be clear it's quite a
finely balanced decision there were
various reviews over the years that
looked at this bit of cabin office and
thought about how it should be
structured and settled on the side of
keeping CCS as a single organization now
as a reason it endured structurally for
20 years that's a sort of very long time
in central government terms and
the decision to split it apart I think
reflected not just the code experience
but some of the other recent challenges
and there was a view that they just
needed to be
a a tighter focus on crisis management
delivery
and they needed to be a view of
resilience which was much less about
detail and more about strategic
resilience of the UK and that would be
better served by separating it out and
connecting it a bit better into
a wider strategy making in government
you see the experience of the covid-19
pandemic
so that we may be clear about this
was it the experience
that the Civil Community secretary had
had of of
having to address
the
arrival of the pandemic and the response
to the pandemic and and of course those
terrible days in January to March 2020.
that led to an understanding that the
system as it was currently formulated
was not adequate to deal with the severe
demands of a
of such a pandemic that the system
hadn't as it turned out
been designed or operated in as best a
way as possible to be able to deal with
managing a pandemic
um it's not it's not sort of quite as
straightforward as that the crisis
management system in government as say
existed before the pandemic or
um you know if you go back five years or
so
um
it's there to try and deliver a crisis
response over a relatively short time
frame
perhaps uh two weeks perhaps a month and
then you return back towards normal and
that's very good for a lot of
emergencies
um but it was also very well developed
for civil emergencies
and a little bit different for security
emergencies
and so essentially the system got pulled
out of shape by
uh by I know the terrorist serious
terrorist incidents in 2017 by uh
planning around brexit by covid by
um Afghanistan by Russia Ukraine by a
whole lot of things so
when this question was looked at it
wasn't looked at with specific reference
to covid but covid is an interesting
example of why there is a strong case
for having capabilities that are able to
run an enduring response not just a
short-term response
and why Upstream factors around
prevention risk reduction and things
like the general fitness of society to
deal with crisis
are important so it was a rebalancing to
try and Achieve those things
a little more directly
your last answer is focused on the
resilience side of it how well did the
specific crisis management capacity that
is to say the cobra
briefing system the Cobra unit the
Cobra room and and the secretary around
it perform
in the early days of the covid pandemic
um well obviously I wasn't there and I
did think that was a sort of module to
matter I think my one of my I suppose
myself I'm so sorry to interrupt
um you have been involved in this area
of government for many years you were a
prime architect the Civil contingencies
act 2004 which is the legal framework
for this system
you were the first director of the Civil
contingency sector to have the unit
split underneath you and you're now
director of the Cobra unit part so you
know why and
the unit was split do you not
yes I think as I've explained there's a
range of factors which contributed to
that decision for some people who
contributed to the review that led to
the decision covert would have been
prominent in their decision making for
many people involved in it it was
actually about other kinds of emergency
and the relatively poor performance in
relation to
International emergencies versus
domestic emergencies that cause them to
want a more common uh purpose around
crisis management inside the central
government but on your specific question
I mean
I wasn't there all I can do is observe
from the outside I think my reflection
is consistent with the point I made a
moment ago which is there's a system
designed to deal with relatively
short-run emergencies
through January February March of 2020
that is what people would have been
experiencing
because at that point it was forming up
it wasn't clear what was happening and
that's why Cobra met repeatedly it's why
that bit of the Civil contingency
secretary was so extraordinarily busy at
that point
obviously is the pandemic then took
pandemic form
there needed to be a more sustainable
governance structure that could carry it
through was the Cobra structure utilized
fully and consistently throughout the
currency of the pandemic or over time
in practice was it replaced by other
structures or other committees or groups
uh yes it was replaced because
as I said the Cobra function is there to
deliver a crisis response to an acute
moment something spins up
you establish control it moves back to
business as usual
a catastrophic emergency like covid and
there are other emergencies that fall
into this category require a different
kind of management it's not necessarily
at the absolute Pace that you get when
you have a crisis you need something
which will keep going week after week
month after month and that's not really
what the Cobra structures are designed
for so without wishing to kind of go
into module module two stuff and Julie
it wasn't ultimately replaced by a covid
task force there are a few sort of
deviations along the way
but that is the model that
um
I mean it's a model essentially it was
used in brexit it's the model which we
ended up using in covid and it's now
part of our
standardized approach was it not in
effect replaced even during the crisis
part of the covert pandemic by
ministerial implementation groups and
also by two committees EXO and Xs which
we're dealing with
the crisis the catastrophic crisis that
was the covid pandemic EXO and Xs were
brexit committees and what how were they
used Mr Hargreaves once the pandemic
arrived
well XO and Xs minus stunning is that
they continue to largely focus on
brexit in January February March of 2020
yeah they would have after in fact the
trade and cooperation agreement was
signed and brexit was over they would
have met if they were meeting them out
much less frequently
um
I mean this is not this is not a period
about which the details were you know
I'm not familiar with the detail of this
period and it isn't something that
you explained to me I'll be asked about
so it's not in the evidence I wasn't
there there's a limit to how much I can
explain about
the number of meetings of that committee
what I would say in you know in relation
to General point is
the early stages of the pandemic were
handled as emergencies National
emergencies are in government using the
Cobra structures they're designed to
deal with
short run emergencies relatively short
run what happens at the start of an
emergencies essentially you've got a
kind of moment of decision or a period
of decisions is this something that will
flare up and then subside or is this
going to become a much longer term
problem
if it's going to flare up and subside
your assumption is that you will pass it
back into business as usual structures
if it's going to be a very enduring
problem then you need to create new
semi-permanent structures to deal with
it while the crisis endures
so that's what we did for kovid as I say
the journey through the Journey wasn't a
linear Journey we had the ministerial
implementation groups
but now our Doctrine would be that we
would move straight into the sort of
covert tussle style structures and if I
think about some of the emergencies
we've dealt with since the pandemic I
can see those patterns in how we've
approached them because some of them
have been dealt with by a more enduring
structure and some of them have been
dealt with just using the covered
mechanism to stand up and stand down
okay give me the sorry the fault is I'm
sure entirely my own
I asked you to what extent did the Cobra
unit
function throughout the currency of the
kobit pandemic the crisis and you said
that it became apparent that once the
crisis had passed
the initial crisis had passed the need
for Cobra had fallen away because it's a
crisis management capacity
my question to you was
was cobra in fact
started to be put to one side what was
were
there an understanding in fact in the
early days of the covert pandemic that
as a crisis Management Facility it
wasn't sufficient and therefore during
the crisis part of the covert pandemic
alternative structures had to be found
and were found
the excess EXO committees the
ministerial implementation groups and so
on
because the Cobra unit wasn't
functioning as well as it had been
expected to do
under the extreme demands of the Cobra
pandemic
that's the question so
I think what I suppose what I'm trying
to explain is
the purpose of Crisis management
structures is to deal with crisis
the Cobra mechanism is designed for that
purpose
the pandemic was a particular kind of
um National challenge it had a an
initial phase of
crisis where we were standing up systems
to try and understand and prepare to
deal with an inbound pandemic
but then it takes the form of
a kind of emergency which exists in the
space between
crisis
where you're desperately trying to
deliver control
and
and the kind of territory of business as
usual where you need to get into a
rhythm and deliver things and work
through problems and establish policies
and so forth
it's not a permanent problem that's why
it makes sense to create a
semi-permanent structure and that's what
so Cobra dealt with
the initial phase
when it became apparent this was both an
extraordinarily complex wide-ranging
problem and one that was likely to
endure new structures were required
the Cobra unit when those extreme
pressures were applied
was found not to be sufficient or
adequate
for coping
with those pressures was it
I think my point is that it wasn't
designed for those pressures was it
sufficient and adequate whether it was
designed or not for those pressures
I think I'm
what I'm trying to explain
um but possibly not successfully that
the covert crisis went through different
phases
and as a consequence Cobra had a role
in the early phase
it was then superseded by more
uh complex structures with greater
capacity because that's what the problem
became all right it's also the case
that whilst the covid crisis ran on
there was still the prospect of other
emergencies so in government terms it
makes sense
to be able to stand down the Cobra
function so if anything else happens
concurrently it's able to deal with that
however I'd also say that
uh
it certainly wasn't a smooth transition
from what I could see from the outside
from
the Cobra function to the more enduring
structures and what we've done since
then is create a much clearer
operational approach towards that
transition so I think if we were going
through the same experience again from
the off we'd understand that we would
need
immediately to begin to prepare
to deliver the covert task force
the pandemic task force
and Cobra would fill the space until it
was up and running
may I now ask you please about the Civil
contingencies Act 2004.
my ladies heard a consular amount of
evidence from Miss Hammond and others
about how this is the act which provides
a legal framework to the whole of the
United Kingdom civil contingencies
Arrangements
I think you are responsible for
the team or you were part of the team
that drafted the bill originally in
between 2002 and 2004 is that right yes
I led the team you led the team and in
very general terms does the ACT provide
for a series of different legal duties
on what are known as category 1 and
Category 2 responders
those responders are
a mixture of local responders
in the case of the dhsc the Secretary of
State and other
departments and
those legal Duties are designed to
ensure that
those bodies which labor under those
Duties are responsible for and and are
made to
plan to draw risk assessments to think
about how they might respond in the
event of an emergency how to liaise with
other bodies how to inform the public
all the moving parts of a civil
contingencies response yes both planning
and response is that a fair fair summary
well to be uh very specific
um
yeah
the duties are largely in relation to
planning
the ACT does not contain a duty to
respond
the reason for that is actually a
um
that depends on the audience sometimes
people regard this as a complex
explanation it's all legal explanation
so you might receive a better well
Milady is a former
vice president of the court of appeal
and a very senior judge side that's why
I'm hoping for an enthusiastic reception
there's a broad public sector
expectation of reasonableness so if you
have a duty to develop a plan that broad
expectation of reasonableness holes that
you will Implement that plan if an
emergency occurs if you have a duty to
respond
then there is a risk that you create an
unfulfillable obligation because of the
circumstances at the time
so the uh
the framing of it and the explanation
accepted by Parliament was that the
combination of the duty to plan and the
expectation of public authorities acting
reasonably would deliver the effect of
response
so that's the that's the kind of
mechanism behind it and that is what's
happening practice but my question to
you was was simply designed to elicit
that
this is a system which imposes legal
obligations for both planning and
response because one of the obligations
on the variety of local responders for
example is to plan as to how they may
respond in the event of a crisis yes
absolutely which is why it is a system
designed to get ready as well as to plan
yes and it's uh sometimes people say why
is there not on explicit GT2 response
that's why okay
after the ACT came into force in in 2004
how many reviews were carried out by the
government as to whether or not that act
was still fit for purpose
um so there would be various informal
informal reviews on the way we're now in
a cycle of post-implementation reviews
which happen every five years we did one
relatively recently that's part of
General best practice in relation to
statute that there is a review
um
so I suppose we've done maybe three of
those perhaps but they've also been
various internal reviews and
considerations of the operation of the
act you've just said
that it was envisaged there would be a
post implementation review every five
years how many post implementation
reviews were there within five years of
the ACT
2004 Act
um so the
post implementation review process as I
said applies to all legislation I'm so
sorry Miss Target how many post
implementation reviews were there within
five years of the 2004 act I don't think
there were any because it's a system
that post dates
The Five-Year window
could you elaborate on that answer
the post implementation review process
doesn't just reply apply to this
legislation it is General best practice
in respect of legislation to do Post
implementation reviews and there's a
process around that
my understanding is that process that
General expectation of post
implementation reviews
was introduced
at some point after the five-year
uh five years elapsed from 2004 when the
legislation was enacted so you're saying
after 2009 so yeah yeah yes so there
wasn't a policy of post-implementation
reviews until after 2009 yes I think so
say that there was a policy
of having a person implementation every
five years after 2004 which is the
question I put to
wasn't quite right there was no review
within five years of the app because
there was no policy of having a post
implementation review
no that wasn't at that point sorry if I
misunderstood your question
um but that's the present system
so there was a review was there not an
internal Review called an enhancement
program review in 2012 and then a formal
post implementation review in 2017.
I thought it was a little before that
was that I might if you've got the dates
then you might be correct I thought it
was 2015 but um
in in the documents with which you were
provided
by the inquiry Mr Hargreaves there is a
document 56230 we we needn't bring it up
but it is the 2017 civil contingency act
post implementation review so would you
agree it's 2017. uh yep so it was 13
years after the Act was brought into
effect
2004 to 2017.
um I
if your question is I don't know what
your question is but if it is is that a
an unreasonably long no I was just
asking you to confirm that despite the
policy of post-implementation reviews
there was no post implementation review
of formal review between 2004 when the
ACT came into effect as it says on the
10th and 2017.
is that correct
if that's the date for the Post
implementation review then yes there is
an awful lot of consideration whether
the ACT works properly or
not and how it operates in practice post
implementation in post implementation
reviews are as I understand it designed
to make sure that everyone across
government is thinking hard about
whether legislation Works in practice
but I think it would be wrong to draw
the inference from that that no one was
thinking about whether the Act was
working I mean to give you an example of
that very practically between 2007 and
2008 are on the team which supported Sir
Michael Pitt's independent review of
um some catastrophic flooding that had
taken place in 2007 as part of that we
reviewed he is an independent reviewer
looked at the operation of the
so it wasn't the case that everyone just
left it idle and it was
um
not being thought about it was very much
a central part of the system and and a
central feature of
debate
can you recall Mr Hargreaves whether
that
semi-formal not the the formal person
implementation review but they're
semi-formal enhancement program review
in 2012 recommended
significant change to the Civil
contingencies Act 2004.
or did it recommend a series of
moderate changes so no departure from
the fundamental premise of the ad which
is that there were these legal duties
imposed on category 1 responders and
different legal duties on Category 2
responders
uh my understanding is that none of the
reviews have recommended a substantial
departure from the broad framing of the
did any review or did the government
ever consider bringing together the
legal duties on category 1 and Category
2 responders so that they were similar
or perhaps even the same
or
extending the legal duties or a variant
thereof
that were in the ACT to central
government
uh
yes and when was that considered well
certainly when I was running the Civil
contingencies Bill team in 2004 2003
after the ACT came into four sorry Mr
yeah but I didn't make it plain no but
after the ACT came into Force
to what extent did the government or any
of these reviews
consider significant
changes to those duties to bring
category one and two responders together
or to impose a light duty on central
government
uh the point I was starting to make is
that these things have been features of
debate around the operation of the ACT
since its original
design and return from time to time as
questions and certainly when independent
reviews or post implementation reviews
or anything else is carried out these
points tend to be considered there is
obviously uh yeah there are obviously
design principles behind the act that
explain the difference in duties that
I'm happy to talk about more if that's
helpful and the absence of Duties on
central government
um
but these are obvious sort of pressure
points in the design of the system and
whether Category 2 responders are doing
enough is always a key question and
whether central government needs more
obligation around it is obviously a
question too when you're thinking about
how the ACT works and how the Civil
contingency system operates so it is the
position
that whilst there may have been some
degree of debate before the Act was
passed
following the enactment
the government itself either internally
or by way of a formal or semi-formal
review has never suggested that there be
wholesale change to those legal duties
or the imposition of a duty on central
government
uh well it was recently as the
uh New National resilience framework we
talk about doing work to consider the
case
on whether there should be a duty on
central government what year in that
National resilience framework is that
work promised by Mr Hargreaves
uh it's not I don't think there's a
specific date attached to it is it 2025
or 2030.
I'm not sure
but
there is a
it's quite a good case for having a duty
on central government departments when
the app was done originally we didn't do
it because it was quite unusual to have
duties on central government departments
the broad principle the broad organizing
principle was that secretaries of state
were able to determine their own
priorities and therefore it wasn't
necessary to have a legal Duty I think
just in in terms of the broad shape of
the way in which law applies to
government departments there's been a
general move towards
having
more duties described particularly
around topics which people believe to be
particularly important and cross-cutting
and so the balance has moved I think
more over time in favor of having a duty
of this kind I mean certainly in my nice
symmetrical bureaucratic mind it would
make sense for duties to apply evenly or
for there to be a clear line of sight
between obligations but as I say it's a
matter that we think does need some
proper consideration should probably be
subjective for consultation and that's
why there's a general commitment in the
framework
but despite that change in thinking Mr
Hargreaves
and the point difference is well made
that there is a case for having a legal
Duty
place on government
the government's own
2022 post implementation review made no
such recommendation did it
he said we'd consider it
did it call for the legal Duty in some
form to be placed on central government
it said we would look at it I mean I
there is
you know I've given you my view I
suppose on the shifting case and there's
a commitment to do that
um the sort of thing which requires any
legislative change is going to require a
consultation
um it wasn't so transparent from the
responses to the framework
consultation that
there was an absolute expectation that
people felt this was necessary but I
think there is a uh a building case a
case that grows over time to do
something specific here why do you think
that's Toby's just for those who are
watching artfulness possibly possibly it
is my uh nicely bureaucratic mind
thinking it but
um
I think it is helpful where
government cares about something in the
round for there to be a consistent set
of expectations and
I think one of the
broad themes of this inquiry might well
turn to turn out to be whether
government takes civil protection
seriously enough in the round in fact
not just government but whether
the UK does
and
on matters like that sending a signal
across government through a statutory
obligation can be very powerful in the
debate which accompanies it can be very
powerful
it's also important that I think that
there is transparency about what
government does and so government can be
held to account and again can foster
political debate on the level of
ambition
so a statutory obligation is a very
effective way to do that it's not
because I think that government
departments
don't take this seriously I just think
there may be room to take it more
seriously could we have please five five
eight eight three
page one
this is the post implementation review
of last year published by the cabinet
office is it not it is if we go forward
one page
we can see that it comes from the
cabinet office lead department or agency
cabinet office
and it's dated the 29th of March last
year
it's a statutory review
the objectives of the measure were
that's to say the original act to
establish a consistent level of civil
protection activity encourage
consistency between the responders
Define the tasks ensure local responders
retain the ability to make decisions
about what planning Arrangements were
appropriate and to provide powers for
the government to make temporary
regulations that last paragraph is that
part two of the Civil contingencies act
2004 yes which provides for emergency
regulations
um apply by a system of regional
directors or or perhaps Governors if the
emergency arrangements are triggered
has that part two of the act ever been
used in the United Kingdom it's not was
it used at the time of covid Mr
Hargreaves no when the uh
when the bill went through Parliament
this point was discussed uh the you know
when we would use it was discuss that uh
some considerable length and there was
concern that government would use it to
freely there's obviously a fair
sort of backstory on these for emergency
Powers by government and so forth
um what government committed to
Parliament at the time is that it would
only use emergency powers where
[Applause]
um it was not possible
to use normal constitutional routes
I think in a sense emergency powers are
a bit of a
kind of constitutional aberration which
has been co-opted into the Constitution
it's a it's a device for making
legislation when it's not possible to do
it through normal routes do you mean
when it's not possible to bring a bill
or statutory yes legislation before
Parliament yes and so I think there's a
misconception sometimes people think
it's a list of things government can do
and it just picks and chooses actually
it's a mechanism for making emergency
legislation at high speed through
secondary legislation
um but often with the kind of reach
primary legislation and it's designed to
be temporary
and designed to have just a much more
much faster mechanism for delivery all
right can we go over the page then
please
what evidence is informed that post
implementation review the national
resilience strategy call for evidence
public consultation workshops and
engagement events
there there were where they're not a
as it says there was a call for evidence
and I think there was a
there were some surveys done and
individual workshops and engagement
events carried out
and then this at three the ACT continues
to achieve its stated objectives Duties
are placed upon local responders with
the principle of subsidiarity ensuring
they retain the flexibility to
collaborate in a way that is suitable to
their specific needs
the recommendations made including
changes to the guidance aim to
strengthen the Fulfillment of the acts
objectives but there's no case at this
stage for a fundamental overhaul of the
legislation the object was the
objectives in the actual performance of
them are broadly fit for purpose the
evolving risk landscape as well as work
on the integrated review commitments to
consider strengthening local resilience
forums and develop a national resilience
strategy May create a need for further
changes to the act in future
Mr Hargreaves in relation to your
earlier answer that this
post-implementation review stated
that there would be and there was a
debate to be had about the imposition of
legal duties on central government
where is that reference where do we find
the reference in the review to that
debate to which you said
it made plain reference it's the
reference to the National resilience
strategy
which emerged as the UK was in its
framework which includes the commitment
to look at that
this review if we go back to the first
aid the first page was in March of last
year
the framework the national resilience
framework was published in December
where is the reference in this review
the reference which you said was in it
to debate being given consideration
being given and debate revolving around
the imposition of a legal Duty on
central government
uh it will be a point raised in
consultation responses from local
resilience forums where is it in the
review Mr Hargreaves
I'd have to look through the review and
find it
so the position of the review was that
no fundamental change was recommended
there should be no significant overhaul
there should be no imposition of legal
duties on central government and no real
change to the
relative legal duties imposed on
category 1 and Category 2 responders is
that correct yeah I mean the ACT
provides for
um local response organizations to carry
out civil protection in a systematic way
assess risks develop plans and so forth
and that holds Good it provides for an
emergency
legislation making mechanism and that
holds Good
um
over time
and you know
partly from the responses to the
consultation around the review partly
from policy debates inside government
partly in response to events we will
contemplate extending elements of the
ACT or other bits of legislation that
apply to emergencies so
um
so this does hold good as a piece of
legislation but that doesn't mean that
there isn't necessarily room for change
coincidentally last year in March your
predecessor Mr Man from whom the inquiry
heard
co-chaired a national preparedness
Commission
review of the CCA 2004 did he not
so understand yeah have you read that
review
his review yes uh I have looked through
it yes yes because of course it's
fundamental is it not to
any proper consideration of the CCA 2004
wow would you agree not quite
um so we get very many
sync pieces from Consultants academics
and
so forth
on
how the system of civil protection
should be organized which reflects their
views the national preparedness
Commission
um
the lay Observer might conclude from the
name that it has some government status
or official role it doesn't it's a sort
of
think tank and the independent review
is independent in the sense that
it has nothing to do with government
not in the sense that this inquiry is
independent for example
that's good to hear Mr Hargreaves the
piece the document that you describe as
a think piece
was a document prepared by the national
preparedness Commission
a relatively August and independent body
and the report which I'm holding up in
my hand
by Bruce Mann Kathy settle and Andy
Taylor
ran
perhaps an away analogous to Mr man's
expert report for this inquiry to some
351 pages
it was an extremely complex
detailed
thorough investigation of the workings
of the CCA 2004 prepared by an
independent body which is solely
concerned with national preparedness
is it just a
think piece
yes
yes it is and if look
there are many organizations
that operate in the field of civil
protection many of them are able to draw
on people with a great deal of expertise
and in government you get many
many of these sent to you and you need
to have a look at them in the context of
an ongoing statutory consultation you
have to take some care around what you
get and you have to give Fair balance to
everyone who might wish to
contribute
um
the national preparedness commission is
a relatively new organization it has
some August people on it but there are
other
other similar bodies available
and it is a very long report which I
looked through with interest because I
have a great deal of respect for Mr Mann
but I did not
prioritize its comments over anyone
else's because that would not be proper
what was the core finding of your
predecessors National preparedness
Commission report
the primary finding in relation to
UK resilience
and the legal framework the structure
the CCA that underpins it
I don't know
you don't know the main conclusional
finding of this piece of work done by
your predecessor and the preparedness
commission into resilience and the Civil
contingencies Act 2004.
uh I could give you a broad description
of the findings but I couldn't tell you
this one was the main one could you tell
us please
a main a general description of the
findings
well there
in the similar vein to the expert report
produced by Mr Man and Professor
Alexander that they
seek a reform of aspects of
the system some of it relates to the
fine detail of how civil Protection work
is done there are some broader proposals
it's slightly different in focus to
what we think the focus should be inside
government
um and what we concluded through our
public consultations and statutory
reviews and so forth
there's a site you know there's a slight
difference of opinion between us and the
team that did that about where the focus
should lie can you analyze or summarize
the focus difference in Focus uh in very
simple terms
the people who wrote that report are
people who specialize in providing quite
detailed advice to people around quite
detailed tasks
the main thrust of working government is
focused on getting more Upstream of
emergencies doing more preventative work
trying to ensure that there is a very
very broad public understanding and
greater public and political engagement
in Risk because that's what shapes
outcomes I think we are interested in
moving the whole system to a better
place and their report is focused on
moving the operation of
those bits of the system that do
specific civil Protection work to a
better place
Mr Hargreaves you've just stated that
there was a
quite catch the word but there was a
difference of view
there's a slight difference of opinion
between us and the team that did that
report but where the focus should lie
the post implementation review carried
out by the government last year as we've
seen said there is no case for a general
overhaul
the primary finding and we'll have
please page 10 of 187729
is that whilst the Act and the
resilience Arrangements it introduced
were a vital step down the road to
building resilient Nation
and whilst they've served the United
Kingdom well over the past 18 years and
provided a sound basic framework
the pace of development has not been
sustained over the past decade in some
areas important areas quality has
degraded as a result UK resilience today
has some serious weaknesses it is not
fit for future purpose in the world the
United Kingdom is moving into is that a
slight difference of opinion
I think there's a lot of that which I
would agree with
and the recommendations
could we have please 272
summary of recommendations the authors
of the report make
117 recommendations but two are of
particular importance
275 please
recommendations 29 and 30.
who should have legal duties
29 the full Suite of category 1
responder duties should be placed on the
organization's currently designated
under the actors cooperating bodies
the United Kingdom government should
pursue and capture and statutory
guidance ways in which the additional
Birds fulfilling the new duties might be
reduced for example by activity
undertaking that multi-local residence
Forum Regional level and then this the
full Suite of category 1 responder
duties should be placed on the United
Kingdom government
so to the extent that the 2022
post-implementation review by the
government said there was no case for
overhaul is it your position now that
you don't agree with that conclusion and
you do agree
with the national preparedness
commission View
note my position is consistent
um
what
some of this is about how to achieve the
ends
the ACT is the act and describes the
obligations that fall on people at the
local level
um
when it comes to
the post implementation View and testing
the fitness for purpose of those
obligations the conclusion of our post
implementation review
uh reflected which reflects the
consultative process that we ran
to which Mr Man contributed through this
report
uh concluded that what we had was
broadly fit for purpose but suggested
some small
changes
I don't disagree at all that category 2
responders should
absolutely take civil protection
seriously the problem with the analysis
is that that doesn't necessarily mean
you do that through the Civil
contingencies Act
Category 2 responders are generally
regulated utilities or other service
providers of critical infrastructure
they are subject to incredibly
detailed
regulatory regimes which impose a wide
variety of different burdens and
expectations on them through very
carefully calibrated regulatory
Frameworks that balance the cost to the
customer with Service delivery with how
they perform in emergencies for example
four
I think we remain in the view that the
obligations on Category 2 responders are
on balance best delivered through those
regulatory Frameworks I do however think
there is a case for contemplating
whether those regulatory Frameworks in
light of the covert experience and other
recent emergencies
are clear enough and enforced with
sufficient vigor
but
if you place Category 2 responders in
category one you place quite a
substantial
um burden on them to get involved in
emergencies which have little to do with
them
say
there are different ways to cut the cake
and there's where I think we disagree
but I don't think we disagree on whether
Category 2 responders who provide
essential Services should have clear
civil protection obligations it's just
that we disagree about whether they
should be in the act the Civil
contingencies act or not
and what about the imposition of legal
duties on the United Kingdom central
government you've you are now recorded
as saying that
although it finds no reflection on the
face of the 2022 review the governmental
review
that it was apparently raising that as
an issue for debate yep
although as I say we can see no
reference to that being the position of
the government and the review and you
say that that is something which the
December 22 resilience framework
has in mind
says that right so again the post
implementation review is about how the
ACT operates
as it says in the passage that you put
up
highlighted
potential extensions to the ACT
would be a matter for the national
resilient strategy as we were saying
called now UK resilience framework
um as I also said earlier
I myself I'm pretty sympathetic to that
recommendation
and uh think it has Merit and probably
more Merit than it has than when we did
the original act so
I think
there
um I'd be in agreement I mean you know
just to say in the round it might be
helpful to say
Mr Mann and Professor Alexander and I
agree on almost everything
we are
do the same thing
there are some constraining factors that
fall on you when you are
an official in government as distinct
from when you are a consultant in the
field of civil contingencies whatever
your background like for example
resource
so if you agree on almost everything
almost everything do you agree there is
an unanswerable case for the imposition
of legal duties
on central government I think you've got
your answer to that master keys should
we have a look then at the document
itself 97685
the resilience framework of December
page one please
so
this was a document produced by the
cabinet office we we heard evidence from
the Deputy Prime Minister yesterday the
tbrit I think he said he wrote the
forward or he suddenly appeared in the
forward and along with his photograph
y
this is a document which
plainly has
the involvement of the Civil
contingencies Secretariat in it before
the splitter card
between
the Cobra unit and the resilience
function now in the resilience
directorate the National Security
directorate presumably you had
um a great deal of involvement in the
production of this framework a very
great deal so I was involved very
heavily you know I oversawed the work on
this through till the summer of 2022 and
after the split
um obviously I retained an interest but
I didn't produce the very final final
draft no you left on July 22 but it must
stand to reason that this document which
is a
well it's in terms of pounds and
kilograms it's a less weighty document
than
the national preparedness commission
report but it's it's a it's a sizable
Beast it presumably the first draft was
drawn up before July 2022 whilst you
were still the director of the Civil
contingency Secretariat uh absolutely I
think that if uh the governor
experienced a bit of turbulence in that
period I think if it hadn't we might
well have published it within my tenure
all right could we look please at page
five
we can see that in the contents page the
way in which the report is divided
there's an executive summary and then
the action plan from the government for
risk responsibilities and accountability
Partnerships communities Investments and
skills and there's a summary of the
framework actions as they're known on
page 72.
foreign
did your then departments framework
document divide up the actions by time
scale so it identified a number of
things that the government was already
doing
and a number of things that would be
done by 2025 and a number of things that
we were done by
2030 yes
perhaps we just look at some of the
things
in relation to which the United Kingdom
government is that it is already taking
action
so in fact
Mr Dunn was asked about this yesterday
under the broad heading of risks
there is a reference to refreshing the
nsra process so look at a longer time
scale multiple scenarios and indeed the
2022 risk
assessment process last year was
was significantly different from the
2019 version because of the reference to
multiple scenarios yes
and then this creating a new head of
resilience
to guide best practice encourage
adherence to standards and set guidance
in which part of the government has a
new head of resilience being created and
and the emphasis is created
which part of the government has a new
head of resilience being created
uh the head of resilience is uh leads
the resilience directorate inside the
cabinet office
there was already a Director of National
resilience in the cabinet office a
full-time post from March 2020 to May
2022 so to what extent was a new head of
resilience created Mr Hargreaves
all right
he's an entirely new role
in what regard is it an entirely new
role
in the sense that it didn't exist before
now exists so it is the part of the job
that I did is
CCS director
um separated out in the fashion that we
talked about earlier so it's a job that
was already a job being done by you and
you're a director it has simply been
hived out from your old job
but it is a head of resilience
to what extent is ahead of resilience
different from a Director of National
resilience which was a pre-existing
full-time post
that was a role in the national security
field less related to this kind of
resilience this is about a head of
resilience that superintendents are
National civil protection system uh
particularly in relation to civil
emergencies
no new post was created was it Mr Argos
other than so far as an existing post
was given a different name I don't know
how more plainly I can say this it's
literally a new post it's a it's a new
post on headcount it's a new person it's
a new title it carries out some of the
functions that were done previously but
because it is a separate the identified
post the person is able to do that with
more focus and weight that I was able to
do or Catherine was able to do or even
Mr Man was able to do when they were
together the reason it's a new person Mr
Hargreaves is that the previous
incumbent of the postal direct from
National resilience happened
coincidentally to leave that post in May
22.
before this report was even published to
go to join a job in the ministry of
Defense
so it's not that there's a change of
person because the new post was created
it's just that the previous incumbent
happened already to have left the post
isn't that correct
it I
it's just not correct or this is this
isn't a different bit of the forest the
fact that the two titles include the
word resilience
um does not mean they
call the same thing all right
there is the government is already
taking action by strengthening United
Kingdom resilience structures by
creating a new resilience function
you've have given evidence how
the existing civil contentious secret
era was split into the the more
practical side the crisis management
side the Cobra unit and the resilience
directorate within the cabinet office
both parts the Cobra unit and the
resilience directorate
are both formed from the pre-existing
civil contingency Secretariat are they
not there is nothing new in either part
that wasn't already in the civil
contingency Secretariat is that
um not quite not quite right so some of
this is about the purpose and focus of
the resilience directorate and that in
turn is shaped by the resilience
framework
our ambition is to be more expansive and
more
um I suppose the certain we would use is
Upstream but preventative in our
approach to civil protection
so that directorate spends less time
looking at the detail of policy and
procedures and on balance
and more time trying to think about
broad operating context of the UK and
whether you can solve problems so do you
want to put your effort into
for example having very detailed plans
to deal with an energy security problem
or do you want the UK to have better
energy Security in the first place
um
is that reference to a new resilience
function
simply a reference to part of the old
civil contingencies directorate which
has been renamed as the resilience
directorate
that's where it starts from but in terms
of its purpose and its focus it is
evolving to a different place
in terms of head count or objectives or
legal scope
in what way has it changed
it would have a different slightly
different framing in terms of its
objectives to
be more clearly focused on
wide reform and prevention
um
but in terms of headcamp
it is uh very similar to what was there
before
page 73 please
but by 2025 the United Kingdom
government is committing to take the
following actions
clarify roles and responsibilities in
the UK government for each nsra risk
conduct an annual survey introduce an
annual statement to Parliament
develop a measurement of socioeconomic
resilience
what is that a reference to what is a
measurement of socio-economic resilience
when you have an emergency
there are
vulnerabilities manifest in different
forms obviously you've heard from expert
Witnesses who've talked about this
um
in in very sort of brief terms there are
three kinds of vulnerabilities we
observe in emergencies
first is sometimes an emergency just
affects a particular category of people
covert is a very good example of that
because there's one particular group
profoundly affected and that was the
elderly
and they were affected disproportionate
sometimes you have
um
vulnerabilities that arise because they
pre-existed and were carried into the
emergency that's a lot of what
um professors talked about
um if someone struggles to access Public
Services
because English is not their first
language before an emergency they will
continue to struggle and mave and
struggle more profoundly during the
emergency itself
the third kind of vulnerability relates
largely to people's ability to shape
their own destiny which largely comes
down to how wealthy people are and how
healthy people are
and so understanding the landscape
of areas that are impacted by
emergencies and knowing that if we are
you know if we Face a particular problem
in a particular area it will be hit more
badly than if that same problem was to
arise in a different place
is a very helpful way to make sure we're
managing the emergency very effectively
and we get further ahead faster
on the protection of people with
vulnerabilities during a moment of
Crisis so that's the kind of work that
we are now advancing
Partnerships further down the page
the government is committed to
providing by 2025
are growing in the United Kingdom
government's advisory groups made up of
experts academics and Industry experts
in order to inform the nsra this may
include establishing a risk-focused
subgroup of the UK resilience forum
now in the body of the report
I won't take your thermostat is
paragraphs 130 and these are the
paragraphs in which this conclusion is
drawn
131 132 133 134 5 and 6.
there are references to how the
government will do this
what ways in which
The Advisory groups will grow but all
those paragraphs do is make reference to
existing structures to Sage to s-tax to
the United Kingdom resilience function
the United Kingdom resilience forum
and they say
the government is committed to inviting
expert Challenge and input it will
actively and regularly draw on expertise
so the question for you is this
in what way
over the next three years or two years
does the government envisage that the
advisory groups will be grown do you
have it in mind to start to to
put into place from scratch a new expert
body a new forum for expert
advice what do you have in mind when you
wrote this report
it was my view when I arrived in post
um at the end of 2020 but one aspect of
our work that was not fully developed
was how we made best use of experts
there are some places where we did it
really well and had really well
developed structures
um Sage is quite an interesting example
of
that
um but more generally there was a
question of whether we were tapping
enough into that expertise
so I was quite Keen to pursue relatively
ambitious change on this so a lot of it
has already been done
um we shifted
um uh with helpful guidance from the
Royal Academy of engineering how we were
using experts in the risk assessment
process it's a really a sort of
aggressively broaden it out and try and
maximize the number of external experts
who could challenge what we were
thinking within that process
we established the UK resilience Forum
which is designed to allow
representatives of all parts of society
to come and sit with government and talk
about resilience challenges
so I was quite Keen to embrace quite
quickly some quite big shifts in how we
used experts I think my expectation
would be that that establishes a trend
and we find more and more ways to
involve them
um over the coming periods so to the
extent that this recommendation
represents radical change we've already
done that
it's now a case of evolving that further
in the same direction
three final errors Please Mr Hargreaves
on page 74
we have the list of actions that will be
done by 2030
eight years hence from the date of the
report so nine years hence from now
the communications on risks proposals to
make Communications on risk more
relevant and easily accessible will be
drawn up work will be done across the
three pillars of Reform to strengthen
lrfs
standards on resilience will be
introduced across the private sector
better guns will be provided to The
Wider private sector
resilience standards for the cni
and a review of existing regulatory
regimes on resilience to ensure that
they're fit for purpose
to what extent has the government agreed
by 2030
to impose any sort of change significant
change on the government itself either
in terms of its legal duties or
core discharge of its primary functions
there isn't a firm commitment
in the way that we might have in some
areas
but as I've
explained in previous answers
it is something which I expect us to
pursue in a
through discussion with those people who
are who have an interest in it and as
I've explained my personal view is that
there is a strong case for moving in
that direction
the bottom bullet point under
Partnerships says the government by 2030
so in nine years time in seven years
time I apologize we'll review existing
regulatory regimes on in resilience does
that simply mean it will again review
the Civil contingencies Act 2004. well
it will again have to do a post
implementation review
but this is about the regulatory regimes
which fall on those outside government
who are adjacent to government that's
the kind of point about the Partnerships
bit of the rib report
um the idea that the framework
introduces is essentially you've got
government which has formal
responsibilities and then you have
the sort of public at large which
includes communities smaller businesses
and so forth but you've got this
category which we talk about as in the
partnership section which is essentially
things which are adjacent to government
and deliver services that the public I
suppose regard as public services but
are not of the public sector
so a lot of these recommendations are
about the Regulatory and other statutory
regimes that exist and strengthening of
those this is the point that the Civil
contingencies act doesn't need to cover
everyone everywhere on everything
because there are lots of other
statutory and Regulatory regimes that
sit alongside it and our organizing
principle around
Supply Public Utilities say is that we
regulate a sector in its delivery
so we regulate the water sector and that
includes how much people pay and
supplies of water and maintenance and
all kinds of things and part of that
overall framework is
obligations in relation to risk and
emergencies
which
can be tested my apologies
paragraph 60
on page 29 of the framework
residence framework it is said this is
said
United Kingdom government will consider
a range of options for improving this
and develop an action plan to deliver
these
thank you including by developing Pros
proposals for formalizing duties on UK
government departments particularly in
respect of working with local resilience
forums and why do local responders on
resilience across the whole resilience
cycle any new Duty would be subject to
an impact assessment
so is the government's position that it
will either
consider a range of options for
developing proposals for formalizing
duties which may consider May recommend
a new Duty or is the government
committed B
to the imposition of a new legal Duty on
central government
and I think the position is as described
there which is there'll be a process to
weigh up the case for imposing those
obligations the detail here specifically
is reference to
if you impose those obligations doing it
in the right way so for example you
would not make every government
Department a member of every local
resilience Forum because they would
collapse under their own weight as a
means cooperating with the local level
through the department for leveling up
homes and having communities
um
so it's not about replacing that say all
right resourcing
one of the points made to melody in the
expert report from Mr Madden Professor
Alexander was that this resilience
framework is silent on resourcing
now a little research demonstrates that
the word resource or resourcing appears
19 times in the report
page 58 I won't bring them all up it
says it's important that investment in
resilience is considered and coordinated
implementation will be iterative and
will take time
there must be a coordinated approach to
our investment in resilience
resilience investment within the United
Kingdom government must be mapped
the government will consider options for
funding models for any future expanded
responsibilities and expectations
is the position of the resilience
framework that there is no commitment
yet to increase resourcing there is
instead a commitment to consider options
for future resourcing
yeah I think that would be fairly
similar summarized as there's no new
money there might be less money but if
there are good proposals
who knows there could be more money
that is the the kind of
honest answer on that point government
is very good if it is spending more
money in telling you it's spending more
money it is not spending more money here
and might spend less that's it when we
say so Mr Hargreaves is an excellent
summary
and the last question concerns
inequalities and vulnerabilities is this
the general position that
none of the planning or the guidance or
very little of the planning or the
guidance pre-covered pandemic in
relation to civil contingencies and
preparedness Across the Nation
paid any regard to the individual
circumstances of the vulnerable or
marginalized sectors in our community
there were references to the important
legal obligation under the
the equalities Act of the public sector
equality Duty
but that in no part of this complicated
factual and legal policy driven process
for contingencies was any Duty imposed
on anybody to consider the specific
needs of particular parts of the
community
the way in which all of our civil
protection is organized
is to run with the flow of existing
functions
so we think that the people who are best
placed to plan for
the delivery of local public services in
an emergency are those people who have
those functions day to day it kind of
runs through everything that we do
and when it comes to
vulnerable group is like Central
organizing principle when it comes to
vulnerable groups
there is a great level expectation on
those organizations already and if you
talk to any local Authority or Public
Health Organization
the needs of vulnerable people is very
very Central to their kind of existence
in their Focus
the expert report on this talks a lot
about the very wide range of guidance
that's
available it is all framed by the idea
though that we are asking
um reminding telling people that they
need to as they would ordinarily Factor
the needs of the vulnerable into their
emergency planning
and then by extension their response
um
the pandemic is quite interesting in
these terms because of its duration
it's very difficult to engage in
social engineering
improve social outcomes during a
two-week emergency but where you've got
an emergency that runs over a year or
two you're making a different kind of
decision you're not just pulling
operational levers
to restore control you're actually
shaping a response over time
and in terms of
the mechanics of how government works
it's less simply an operational task and
has more of a policy element and so what
was described by your expert Witnesses
is really very interesting and thought
provoking about how government
introduces
best practice it would apply to policy
during the policy making in normal
day-to-day business
into emergencies of long duration where
vulnerabilities May emerge and there's
enough time for a kind of feedback loop
we did this it didn't work properly
let's redo it again which you wouldn't
get in a tighter crisis
my lady
there are no questions posed by the core
participants which I have
not already addressed in my own
examination or in relation to which you
have declined permission
that being said there are no further
questions thank you very much in which
case we shall break now I shall return
at 25 to 12. thank you very much indeed
for your help Mr Hargreaves
foreign
it's Keith I'm a lady the next Witnesses
Professor sir Chris Woody
if Christopher could be sworn please
I swear by almighty God I swear by
almighty God that the evidence I shall
give the evidence I give shall be the
truth shall be the truth the whole truth
the whole truth but nothing but the
truth
Tuesday
pure assistance
Milady is aware that you've provided a
number of witness statements
both to this module and in fact to
module two
whilst I
ask questions could you please remember
to keep your voice up so that we may
hear you properly and also so that your
evidence may be recorded stenographer
and if I ask a question which is not
clear please don't refrain from asking
me to repeat it
um
so Chris you are as is very well known
an infectious disease
epidemiologist and acute medicine
clinician
you
are and you have been now for some time
the chief medical officer for England
you were appointed on the 2nd of October
2019 as chief medical officer for
England
and in essence that is the chief medical
advisor to his Majesty's government is
that correct
was your predecessor Professor Dame
Sally Davis
and have your deputies been a one-time
Professor sir sir Jonathan fan Tam until
2022 and Professor Dame Jenny Harrison
till
uh 2021 when she became chief executive
of the United Kingdom Health Security
Agency
those are all correct um the one thing
just to minor amendment is that I
stopped doing acute medicine when I took
up the road of chiefs medical officer in
2019 but I still do infectious diseases
and indeed over the covid period did 12
weeks wrote it on the Awards for covid
over that period so I saw it firsthand
and if I can say to the families who are
here I saw the extraordinary impact and
Devastation that had for individuals and
the families
thank you
before that before you were Chief before
you appointed chief medical officer were
you the chief Scientific Advisor for the
Department of Health and Social care
between 2016 and
2021 so there was a an overlap in fact
yes
were you also formerly ahead of the
National Institute for health research
Nia Channel yes and I believe that you
were interim government Chief Scientific
Advisor between 2017 and 18. all right
you were the chief Scientific Advisor at
diffid
you were until very recently a member of
the Executive Board of the World Health
Organization
and you remain
I believe a member of the Department of
Health and Social
uh cares
executive committee xco
there are if I may say too many
honorifics um qualifications and
fellowships with a huge range of August
bodies for me to list them
but you are by training a professor of
public and international health and you
were a professor of public International
Health at the London School of hygiene
and tropical medicine and
perhaps primarily a fellow of the Royal
Society The Academy of Medical Sciences
the Royal College of Physicians and an
honorary fellow at a number of other
organizations
for the particular purposes of
addressing the issue of preparedness
were you involved in the response to
many United Kingdom and global
medical and wider emergencies I was over
quite a period of time
were you concerned therefore with the
response to the HIV emergency Health
Emergency to the Ebola emergency and the
emergencies connected to the zika
outbreak abroad and the novichok
poisonings in Salisbury and Amesbury
that's it I taught of those uh and the
HIV was as a condition and rather than
as a member of government
thank you
have you also been at various times
a chair or a member of a number of the
important advisory disease committees
which exists within the United Kingdom
yes all right well we'll come back to
the detail of those in in due course and
also
and it's relevant again to this module
together with the chief medical officers
for Scotland Wells and Northern Ireland
and the government Chief Scientific
Advisor and the NHS National medical
director and a number of other people
including relevant deputy chief medical
officers in the United Kingdom
did you write what is known as the
technical report on the covid-19
pandemic in the United Kingdom I did and
this was aimed specifically at our
successes so it's in places quite
technical as the title implies but it is
I hope uh helpful to this inquiry and
indeed more generally to lay out some of
the scientific and medical issues
um so that we may get our bearings is it
a report a very considerable report
addressing the questions of disparities
research situational awareness modeling
testing contact tracing npis Care Homes
pharmaceutical interventions
improvements in the care of covid and
Communications so traversing in fact the
whole scope
of the response to covid and the
preparedness for covid with which you
are directly personally and
professionally concerned yes all right
I don't propose scripture to ask you
about matters which more properly fall
within the scope of module two so maybe
make it absolutely plain
um
there will be no questions today about
the government's response to the
Pandemic those are matters for the
future
I'd like you instead to focus please
firstly on some of the structures which
play a very important role in the
emergency preparedness response and
resilience and response system in the
United Kingdom
as the chief medical officer are you
assisted by a body known as the office
of the chief medical officer if so what
is that so I'm I am no fortune to have
very able but small group as Dean Sally
said in her evidence normally this runs
as it does at the moment around 12
people which includes myself and the
deputy chief medical officers and then
some private secretaries and medical
Public Health registrars
with the benefits of the hindsight that
comes from responding to the the covid
pandemic is there anything that you
would wish to say about the size of that
office or this the the degree of
Assistance or the resources associated
with it did it stand
the test of time in light of the
terrible demands of the pandemic I my
view is that the size which expanded up
to about 19 people that Peak during the
pandemic was the right one for the job
we were asked to do which was advisory I
there were others who helped me with
some of my more executive functions
because I was still in the early stages
running the National Institute for
health research that was a significant
slightly different body of work but my
general view is a small very very good
group is easier to provide clear advice
to people than a much more larger and
often more unwieldy group
turning them to some of the other bodies
concerned in the eprr system
is it important to distinguish between
those
bodies
which provide on a permanent basis
scientific advice
and those bodies which are to use a
terrible modern colloquialism stood up
to deal with the response to civil
emergencies does that
divide exist and why does it matter
so that divide does exist there are a
number of bodies which give advice
irrespective of whether there's an
emergency or not some of those are
relevant in emergencies if they happen
in their area of work so for example the
group nerve tag which will be may come
back to either now or in later modules I
know you've had previous evidence on it
was very important in this emergency and
it also runs between emergencies but
there's an apparatus that stands up
particularly around Sage for major
emergencies which it acts both as a way
of funneling information to central
government in a coherent way but also
and I think this is important in the way
we think about it as a coordination
mechanism for how to prioritize the
advice that's given so I actually think
during emergencies there is better
coordination of scientific advice than
there is out with emergencies and I
think that actually may be a weakness
between emergencies
in your witness statement you state that
the United Kingdom science advisory
system and we are concerned only now
with the the particular committees and
the particular groups that give specific
advice is a complex one and not perfect
but is considered to be one of the
stronger ones internationally is it your
view that whilst changes could be
debated and recommended perhaps to some
of the individual committees and their
remit their diversity and their
constitution
in a general sense there is no systemic
weakness in the system by which
scientific advice is provided
pre-emergency
I think that there is there are no
structural problems that I think need to
be changed there can be issues as you
say of detail I'm always quite cautious
of changing structures as a way of
trying to fix problems however I think
what this did demonstrate was that
whilst we the system can be extremely
fast moving during an emergency I think
it is sometimes less well coordinated
between emergencies and I think from
that some problems actually arose
is that's a problem which which emanates
from the way in which committees may be
brought up to speed a great speed in the
face of an emergency and and therefore
placed under very considerable pressure
by contrast to to their normal operating
procedures I think it's more that it's
very clear they're operating around a
single aim and all feed into that single
aim whereas the danger in between uh
issues and I think Dane Sally has raised
the issue of uh where we imaginative
enough where we radical enough in our
thinking for example about prevention I
think it is quite difficult to be
radical when you've got a very diffuse
system it's much easier to do that
actually when you've got the whole
system operating together so the sage
mechanism allowed for much faster
decision-making and much more focused
and in my view more radical thinking
that occurred between emergencies but
sages of course a response body exactly
we'll come back to the issue of group
thinkers has been described a little
later but in terms again of the
structures that's to say the existence
of the various committees putting aside
the detail perhaps of their composition
and scope
would in your view any significant
change in the structures lead to
unappreciable Improvement not in my
theme you need to have people who are
similar enough that they can have a
serious conversation and different
enough that they can challenge one
another and bring different perspectives
and I think the structure is probably a
reasonable point between the two
extremes is there any better
International system used by other
countries which is worth emulating or
not we've looked around the the world I
mean there are bits of other systems
certainly in the the global West and
North which we've learned from but I
think generally the UK is seen to be a
very strong system I think what we don't
probably have as much sight of is for
example systems in China or some of the
other countries in Asia and I think it
is probably an opportunity to rethink
other things we could learn from those
parts of the world but certainly in
Europe in North America and other
countries we normally deal with I think
most people would see the UK as having a
strong system
may I ask you about two generic risks
that you identify in your second witness
statement concerning the the personal
composition of these advisory groups
that is to say the the members of the
groups firstly do you identify that
going forward there is a a growing risk
in relation to the availability of
the regularly
qualified and and expert members to to
um to take part in this committee work
is there a problem developing in
relation to
the ability of such experts to make
themselves available for potentially
quite lengthy periods of time and I
think we've been extraordinarily Lucky
in the UK and having a tradition of the
best people uh doing this and this has
happened over very many years I think
there are two potential threats that we
need to be very alive to the first of
which is the University system has got
more uh hawkish if I can put it that way
about recovery of time and what what are
the people that they're paying spending
their time doing I see this as a very
major part of the contribution of
science to society but obviously for
individual institutions that's an issue
so that's a kind of mechanistic one
and then I do think that what occurred
during covid where the level of abuse
and in some cases threat to people who
volunteered their time is an extremely
concerning one and one we should be very
firm in saying that the society very
much appreciates the work of these
people who put in enormous amounts of
time usually at no recompense
you would no doubt have given some
considerable thought to that issue
because of course you were uh I'm very
sorry to say on on the your recipient of
of some of that disgraceful behavior
um is there anything that can be done
other than calling it out and and making
it absolutely plain that the inevitable
consequence of such sort of abuse will
be a diminution in the cooperation and
assistance is given by people such as
yourself I think the main thing is to
make sure the people who do this
understand that their work is very
thoroughly appreciated by the great
majority of the population which I think
it is
again still at quite a high level
may ask you to consider please the the
departmental
Chief Scientific Advisor system to which
you refer in your witness statement is
this a system under which as my ladies
Had Each major gum department has or
should have in place a senior scientist
to provide advice to coordinate with
other Chief scientific advisors across
government in a in a cross-governmental
way
to give advice to each
department and also to ensure that there
is a consistency of approach across
government
yes I think that the most of the chief
sounding advisors not absolutely all are
seconded in from Academia either
part-time or full-time the advantage of
this is it brings some degree of
Independence it brings some degree of
external challenge but it also brings in
different expertise and I think this was
seen during covid so many of the chief
scientific advisors were doing roles in
the covert response which were relevant
to their particular skills although it
wasn't the thing for which they've been
brought in so for example Professor
Watson the foreign common wealth and
development office is a specialist in
Social uh some aspects of social science
as well as mathematical Sciences she was
very influential Dame Angela McLean now
the government two standing advisor was
then at mod the defense department but
she was an academic epidemiologist and
modeler of great Renown and so on so
people brought their personal skills
alongside their Department full skills
and I think this is a very useful part
of our response
does the close working Network between
departmental Chief scientific advisors
in each department allow for Rapid
transmission of technical information to
each department yes and it allows for a
degree of essentially technical
discussion between people who know one
another and then they can disseminate in
their Department in the way that is best
suited for that department
does the fact that Chief scientific
advisors come from different professions
and different parts of the scientific
world
assistant anyway in in the ability to
challenge Orthodoxy to to to ensure that
the thinking is is sufficiently lateral
and and
opened a challenge I think it helps but
I think we should all acknowledge that
the wider you can go in terms of uh
external challenge the better because
science works best when you have
external Challenge from multiple
directions
again before we look at Sage in detail
and again at quite a high level of
generality
um
do you have any views as to whether or
not there is sufficient diversity within
the scientific world
in terms of the composition of these
various committees and advisory groups
um to ensure that
essentially the advice that's been given
to government is is sufficiently Broad
well I think you've always got attention
the more you broaden things out the
wider the range of uh experiences and
skills and diversity of thinking you get
and the more unwieldy the committee
becomes and I think what you've got to
do is get a balance between those two
what you don't want is everybody going
around the table saying a single thing
no ability to challenge because it's too
big so it's it's getting the balance
between those two but I think on the
whole the system works reasonably well
but the big bus is of course it also
depends on an enormous amount of science
underpinning it and it should depend on
people being able to challenge what's
said from the external environment as
well because that is that provides some
of the additional challenge into the
system
turning then just to four of the
particular groups to which you may
reference in your witness statement
firstly nerve tag the new and emerging
respiratory viral threats Advisory Group
of which
Milady has had much in the last two
weeks
is this an expert Committee in fact of
the dhsc is it a a committee which
advises the the chief medical officer
and through you ministers and the dhsc
and other government departments in
relation to as it says on the tin new
and emerging respiratory viral threats
correct
Point made by
Professor Whitworth and Dr Hammer in
their report which I'm sure you've seen
is that
one potential weakness with nerve tide
is as it says it only considers
respiratory viruses and not the whole
range of emerging infections is there a
case for a tweak in the scope of any of
these committees or groups particular
nerve tag to ensure that that nothing
does fall between two stools
I think there is a potential weakness on
this actually as I laid out in my
written witness statement there are
broadly five routes by which uh
infections which could become epidemics
or pandemics can go through nerve tag
covers respiratory but it doesn't cover
the others for example touch or sexual
uh transmission or mediocre remember
that the last very big pandemic we had
affecting the UK was HIV which was
completely different as a sexual
sexually transmitted intravenously
transmitted infection completely
different route of transmission
completely different disease there was a
body
um called the national expert panel for
new and emerging infections a bit of a
mouthful net knee which was did have
that wider role but that was the reasons
I'm not actually sure of I wasn't
involved in this decision uh stopped I
was previously chair of it so I knew
it's work and it stopped I was excited
so I ceased to be chair before it
stopped yes and I I think there is an
argument for saying we need to cover
these other areas because risks do come
from multiple directions
did netany provide expert advice
directly to the CMO on the public health
risks Associated from new and emerging
infections generally so not respiratory
virus that was her job
um and was it in fact disbanded about 10
years ago does that sound about right
that's about right yeah
one of the points came back to nerve
attack made by a number of Witnesses in
particular your your colleague Professor
sir Jonathan fan Tam was that
nerve tag because it is concerned with
new and emerging respiratory viral
spreads
um was in his View and and is not in his
view asked to project threats that might
emerge in the future that there is
obviously a lack of prospective
examination because it's not concerned
with on its in terms of its terms of
reference but then the other than a a
present continuing emerging viral threat
is that a weakness in the scope I think
it realistically the the danger is you
can end up with almost infinite numbers
of theoretical threats
the sensible thing is to concentrate on
threats which may look small at the
moment but could expand very
significantly so for example uh MERS
virus another coronavirus currently has
relatively small numbers of cases every
year but it could expand very rapidly we
definitely need to have information
about that just to give an example I
think thinking about theoretical ones is
much more difficult but you do need to
understand the range not you you need to
but we all need to understand the range
of possible scenarios ranging from very
very high mortality very low mortality
different routes of transmission
different forces of transmission
different age structures of disease and
that doesn't you can't ask a single
committee to cover all of that
Waterfront what you do need to do is to
allow for the possibility that they
could come from almost any place
does nerve tag sit continuously or at
least perpetically but it sits from time
to time to consider constantly new and
emerging threats or does it respond to
and act upon specific commissions from
the government so might a government
Department say of nerve tag could you
please look at this particular issue or
is it open to nerve tag to raise of its
own volition a matter which it believes
is of concern or should be of concern to
the government so certainly it's
certainly able to I mean when I've
chaired scientific advisory committees
or equivalents my kind of view is always
been about an 80 20 rule which is if you
spend all of your time considering
things that only the committee are
interested in the government is not
then you're probably not going to get
much uh traction equally if you're only
restricting yourself to the things which
the government has raised you may be
missing either important things which
the experts spot or occasionally issues
which are inconvenient to government but
need to be aired so I think that most of
the time should be spent on things the
government has asked about but a
significant minority should be spent on
things the government has not asked
about for whatever reason and is that an
is the drawing of that
difficult dividing line a matter that
should in your view be left to the
expertise and good sense of the the
members of the group as opposed to
the application of some sort of
prescriptive system yes I mean the
numbers I made was a made-up number but
I'm illustrating the kind of rough
divisions I think there should be this
really should be in the hands of the
independent chair they're selected to be
one of the experts in the country
they're usually a very senior academic
and they can discuss with the
Secretariat and say this is what I want
to do but my view is there should be
some latitude otherwise the Committees
can become the creatures of government
which is not the right approach
Professor Whitworth and Dr Hammer
referred to a second group the human
animal infections and risk surveillance
group has
which is a multi-agency cross-government
horizon scanning and risk assessment
group with I think a number of
representatives from across government
on it
is its scope
despite the fact well it says as it says
annual infections it considers only
potentially zoonotic infections such as
their animal infections and not the
whole range of emerging protections that
is correct although there is a very
large overlap in fact but again it
starts from zoo and so it's set to us
from animal diseases and works out which
of those have zoonotic potential that is
to say have the potential to jump from
animals to humans that's really what its
principle aim is it's got a slightly
widering but that's its principle but
there's no question is thereof
there being a a gap between two stools
whether or not the infection is zoonotic
or otherwise there is an existence a
group or a committee which we'll be
looking at
the issue of an emerging threat
could I could I I apologize just ask you
to keep your answers to make your
answers a little bit slower
and whilst if I may say so your evidence
is is
um wonderfully clear it's very difficult
to transcribe
um enthusiasm my enthusiasm is running
away with me
um so so my question is
um
whether or not uh in an emerging threat
is zoonotic or not there is at least an
existence a committee or a group that
will be keeping its eye firmly fixed on
the nature of the emerging threat there
should be yes right
um the last committee I wanted to ask
you about is the advisory committee on
on dangerous
pathogens acdp this is a dhsc committee
to what extent does that committee
concerned as it is with dangerous
pathogens overlap with those committees
to deal with zoonotic and other emerging
infections so that committee which I
very briefly chaired again when I was
outside government
when I started uh uh was uh is
principally aimed at infections we know
about and which if they were introduced
into a laboratory for example could be a
risk to the people who are dealing with
it or could be a risk to people in
hospital or people who come into contact
with someone they tend to be the
diseases that have got very high
mortality so something like Ebola where
uh untreated maybe 70 percent of people
who catch it would die and so those very
high consequence infections will be the
most common but a variety of other
infections which have to be handled
particularly carefully in terms of
either their clinical or their
laboratory management
and so standing back is a your view that
the broad range of advice
impendously provided by the various
groups and committees is right there is
no significant issue in relation to
Omission or to Greater degree of overlap
or of ministers in the government not
receiving the advice in a general sense
that it requires
I think that in terms of identifying
risks I think that the Waterfront is
quite well covered there are some gaps
which uh but they are not huge ones in
my view I I think in terms of what the
response should be I think that's a much
more a much less certain that that is
covered well by the current system let
us then look at that please do are you
in fact really referring to Sage to
which you referred earlier which is the
Primary Response body stood up to use
that phrase in the event of an emergency
to provide of course scientific advice
on emergencies
well if if I may uh just go back one
step from that
yeah I think central to a lot of the
debate that you've had over the last uh
several weeks and in the excellent
written statements the inquiry has been
the point that we should have had a more
uh imaginative approach to how we would
respond to a major pandemic whether it
was influenza something like influenza
or indeed something else
but this would require quite radical
changes in the way people think now I
don't think the current committee system
which is excellent is designed to inject
radicalism of that size into the uh
situation it's very good at responding
it's very good at Horizon scanning in my
view relative to what is realistic so I
think that is potentially the big
weakness in the system how do you inject
radicalism into the system rather than
how do you expect how do you I how do
you respond to expertise
the issue of how to inject radicalism or
to put another way how to challenge
group think effectively or to put it
another way to increase the diversity of
you in a committee
is a different issue is it not to the
question of whether or not structurally
this is an important and valuable
committee to have yes exactly and my
point is simply I think the system is
very good at what it does but we should
recognize there is there is a gap in the
system
could we look firstly then at the
structure and then we'll return
please to the
to to the group think issue or the the
radicalism issue
you have vast experience of sage because
you attended Sage
um in your
previous uh knife as a interim
governmental Chief Scientific Advisor
also as a departmental chief Scientific
Advisor and of course now currently is
the the CMO and I think as an observer
for differed when you were the chief
Scientific Advisor there
does sage sit permanently or is it
brought together in the event of an
emergency so Sage is brought together
only in an emergency
the way in which it's brought together
has changed over the last decade so it
used to be that it would only uh meet if
it was asked to buy cabinet office
because Cobra mechanism which you were
hearing about in your last session was
brought together that's changed now and
that's changed actually as a result of
the Ebola crisis in West Africa we
recognized that Sage had to be possible
to bring together irrespective of
whether a cobra had been called if
something looked big enough
to need
multi-departmental multi-scientific
views and it's called by the government
Chief Scientific Advisor I know you're
hearing from Sir Patrick Valance later
but it also can be in it requested by
other government Chief scientific
advisors in terms of departmental
scientific advisors or the CMO
because it's convened by the government
Al Chief Scientific Advisor does that
person also chair sage in all
eventualities but not in the event of a
health emergency the government advisor
will I always either chair or a co-chair
say to Sage if you have a Savage it
means you've got a very big problem and
therefore that would clearly be a
priority for the government Chief
Scientific Advisor of the day and they
might have to delegate it from time to
time but that would be the principle for
health emergencies is usually an
assumption that the chief medical
officer would co-chair and in previous
emergencies I have co-chaired with
previous gcsas where it was seen that
that my expertise was such that that
would be helpful
in the event of a health emergency as of
course covid was
you therefore chaired Sage along with
Sir Patrick balance yes I mean I think I
think realistically he chaired most of
the time he's an excellent chair but I
was the co-chair and would stand in for
him and would agree the agenda and sign
off the minutes
and the benefit of course of having the
chief medical officer co-chair sage in a
health emergency is that the chief
medical officer will bring his or her
medical clinical
epidemiological experience whatever it
may be to the table
to what extent can Sage call upon the
expertise of experts
outside the membership of sage so for
example from some of the other
committees and groups to which we've
referred or individual experts and
scientists out with any of those groups
so Sage is set up to answer the problem
that it was actually originally if if
for example you have a volcano you will
bring in the best volcano experts from
the UK and potentially internationally
if that's the right thing to do for for
the covert emergency this involved many
scientists who were on the expert groups
but it also involved other people who
were not on those groups but were seen
to have National or International
expertise the membership shifts there's
no permanent membership of sage the only
person who is permanent in Sage is the
chair the government Chief Scientific
Advisor the other members are entirely
to deal with the problems that are in
front of the committee and this is to
make sure you've got the right people in
the room but not a large group of people
making it impossible to get to final
decisions
if Sir Christopher the membership shifts
per Siege and if sage has the ability to
call upon the experience of individual
members of that committee with vast
professional scientific experience and
it can call upon the expertise of the
various subcommittee or other committees
to which you've referred and it may call
upon
the the advice and assistance of
individual experts
why is that an issue about the diversity
of opinion or the
the absence of of
perhaps sufficient challenge or the
absence of necessary radicalism
well I think I would say I hear I'd like
to clearly separate between during an
emergency and the period leading up to
an emergency actually my view is during
an emergency the sage mechanism stood up
as essentially the conductor of the
orchestra you've got all around that
lots of expert committees and feeding
into their many many scientists the
major academies and so on so the
mechanism can be fast-moving and it can
pull sounds from multiple directions I
actually think it works pretty well
and I don't really think despite what a
few people have said that there was any
weakness in the radicalism or uh change
in opinion of sage once the emergency
was underway I think where things have
and I'm happy to go through details of
this where I think there is an issue is
between emergencies there is no sage and
therefore what you have is large numbers
of expert committees doing perfectly
good job on their own but what you don't
have is an overall structure and you in
the only situation they would end up in
a radical place in my view is if they
were challenged usually by political
leaders who said this is a very big
problem I want you to think really
widely about this or perhaps by an
external body or agency or resilience
Institute or whatever it might be
possibly but I mean let us take and I
think I'm going to give a longer answer
because I think this is so Central to
all the evidence you've had so far
to say given the importance of the
answer please keep it as slow as you can
right I apologize
um the uh
the question about should we move beyond
the individual components of uh what
were termed in covid npis
non-farthingical interventions rather a
clumsy term essentially meaning social
measures many of which are long-standing
quarantine individual isolation closing
schools many of these go back to the
Middle Ages or Beyond these are not new
ideas however the very big new idea was
the idea of a lockdown this is often all
the npis are sometimes called locked
down by some commentators but in I'm
talking here very very specifically
about the state saying people have to go
to go home and stay at home except under
very limited circumstances a very
radical thing to do mandatory really big
thing
I would have thought it would be very
surprising without this being requested
by a senior politician or similar that a
scientific committee would venture in
between emergencies into that kind of
extraordinarily major social
intervention with huge economic and
social ramifications so that's my point
is that it is very difficult for the
Committees to go beyond a certain level
unless they are asked to do so
externally to
of course module 2 will return to the
issue of
the merits of mandatory quarantining and
I emphasize
that's a very helpful introduction to
the topic but but we really can't go
further into that now
but coming back to the point that the
central point that you make which is
that between emergencies because there
is an absence of common aim a common
imperative to address all aspects of the
instant emergency there is a risk
that all the various committees will
fail to address sufficiently or think
deeply enough about the possible
ramifications or the consequences or the
the steps that have to be taken in
relation to a prospective future
emergency
that is that is that is the point about
mandatory quarantine that is exactly
right if I can just add one important
Rider to that the idea that the UK alone
is thinking about this of course is
incorrect this is an international
scientific effort and the situation we
found ourselves going into covid the UK
was in the middle in my view of the uh
mainstream of world scientific opinion
so it wasn't that we were on our own
isolated in a particular position we had
a position that was identical to
virtually all other nations unaware of
will return to this issue later but but
you are aware of course of of all
neighbors before your time as CMO
exercise Alice which was the MERS
related exercise
and my ladies had evidence that
amongst the many recommendations and
learnings from exercise Alice
well actions
relating to the development of a MERS
Coronavirus emerge COV serology assay
procedure for scaling up capacity
the production of a briefing paper
on the South Korean outbreak it's only
MERS
with details of how to deal with Port of
Entry screening
option plans for using
evidence and cost benefits for
quarantine versus self-isolation so
mandatory quarantining lockdowns versus
self-isolation
and the development of plans for
Community sampling and also for Mass
contact tracing
so all those issues which were to which
you've referred to Christopher
were all potential
ramifications or Consequences of a
future prospective emergency as at 2016
but they were all flagged up
in one way or another admittedly not in
the highest profile way in 2016 as a
result of exercise Alice
so why were they not taken further
within or perhaps out with the various
committees which were constantly sitting
to consider such issues so I thought the
report on exercise Alice in the report
the exercise itself actually were very
good and very useful I don't think so
and I also think that it was sensible to
do all of the recommendations that were
put into it so I thought they were all
sensible
but actually they were incremental uh
restatements of existing thought in in
fact they weren't a new approach they
were essentially bringing together and
saying we've got to be more uh
systematic about something we were
already thinking about aiming at the
kinds of things that were seen with SARS
and with MERS which were relatively
modest scale outbreaks compared to covid
but still very significant infectious
outbreaks so the evolution analyst was
aimed at that problem it wasn't aimed at
a pandemic problem I think the other
very good report that it goes alongside
it is Dan Deidre Heinz report after the
pan flu uh so the the
H1N1
2009 flu pandemic and that also has a
number of very sensible recommendations
both of those I think would have helped
us but I think same thing either of us
sort of led to the completely different
approach to a pandemic which developed
during the first few weeks of covid
MERS
is as it says on the tin of Coronavirus
there was undoubtedly debate about these
important steps important plans and
important policies
were they not
let me start again
if they were not pursued further or at
least to full fruition
and put into place by way of planning
for a pandemic
was that because it wasn't sufficiently
recognized that a high consequence
infectious disease
perhaps a viral disease
could have
the necessary characteristics and
variables that would make it into a
full-blown pandemic like an influenza
pandemic
or because administratively the
processes and the work streams are
simply not sufficiently by the
government or both I wasn't involved in
any of the decisions around this I think
I I just simply I can't answer that in a
useful way
all right
um you've given evidence about the need
for diversity and and
radicalism and and challenge in some in
relation to the the standing
committee and group structures but we
deliberately didn't come on to Sage the
response body
without going too far into the issue
because it is for module two but to
close off this this this matter
is there an issue about the diversity of
composition of contribution in Sage
in the context of a health emergency so
to be blunt
is there an issue but I'm not asking you
to to resolve today is there an issue
for future consideration about whether
or not the the outstanding experts and
professionals and scientists who are on
the committee were sufficiently diverse
themselves perhaps two-way towards
biomedical
expertise as opposed to economic and
social
well I think that wraps up several quite
important issues um can I can I take his
two different chunks please
um
the first uh is the the issue about was
there enough diversity in the uh in the
group I mean you know if you ask that in
an objective way the answer to almost
any group will be no uh but in terms of
what is manageable given that you have
to have a committee that covers as much
of the ground as possible and has to
move very fast so just in covid we often
had to have a meeting that finished half
an hour before the Cobra meeting or an
equivalent so you have to be able to do
things quickly uh there is it it is my
view is it was a reasonable balance
between coherence and challenge however
it there is undoubtedly a loss of
benefit from getting external challenge
so the challenge doesn't all have to be
within the committee you I think there
would be strong Arguments for having
mechanisms for actually essentially
putting an antithesis to the thesis
that's put forward by a body like Sage
people talk about red teams whatever
lots of ways of describing it but the
principles I think are perfectly
reasonable actually but I think that
might be a more efficient way to do it
than to try and have every single aspect
of every opinion uh represented in the
one committee I think that would be is
that tricky is that to take it from
another angle
people because some are all of you are
as described I think by your colleagues
Sir Patrick valance's license dissidents
it is in the nature of being an expert
and a particular scientific expert that
there's a tendency to challenge
Orthodoxy you you it's part of the
nature of the job you perform uh I I
think that some scientists uh over uh
over emphasize their own unorthodoxy
there is a scientific Orthodox at any
point and in fact the job of sage and I
think this is a something which I'm sure
will be very Central to our discussions
in the next module is not in my view to
provide radical ideas it is to say this
is the central position of Science in
the world at this moment in time
accepting the science and they move on
so it's not actually designed to be a
radical body
as such it's designed to be an expert
body those those two are not necessarily
contradictory but they they certainly
the aim of it is is to provide a Central
View right so you have a second part yes
so but the the second part is you asked
very specifically on economics
and I think this is a very important
question
um I the problem you've got is that the
people around Sage
tables are not best placed to provide
challenge to one another or to an
economist coming in if you had two
economists on stage
uh you would not be in a situation where
Sage would suddenly become an
economically extraordinarily competent
body he would be a competent scientific
body with two economists on it which
does not strike me as actually answering
any terribly useful question uh the very
very narrow bit where I think that sage
in the health emergencies can have a
role is in health economics which is a
very specific bit of microeconomics
which is generally in medical schools
and alongside them rather than to one
side doctors know how to understand
Health economics but that's the big
macroeconomic questions the fiscal
questions which were Central to the
debates not just in covid but in most
other emergencies I've seen
that requires a completely different
skill set and I don't think Sage people
including myself have the competence to
assure government that they've
considered the economic problem and they
can now give a central view on it I
think that would have to be done
separately
thank you very much because that
obviously is a great assistance in terms
of alerting us to some of the issues
which will need to be explored in
Greater detail
in module two in the context of the
actual response by Sage to the um
to the particular emergency can I then
come on to the issue of planning
assumptions
and the
the issue of the
2011 pandemic influenza strategy of
course again before your time as a CMO
and and some of the
doctrinal thinking which is being open
to criticism by a number of witnesses um
based in writing in orally before the
inquiry in the 2011 United Kingdom
influenza pandemic preparedness strategy
you yourself say in your witness
statement that in November 2018
it was recognized that there was a need
to refresh that strategy and the work
was to be led by the dhsc with oversight
from the chief medical officer and the
deputy chief medical officer but the
work on the update ceased in March 2019
as a result of
reasons which the inquiry is now very
familiar namely the reallocation of
necessary resources or the necessary
reallocation of resources towards EU
exit preparations
to what extent was it recognized
generally
either in the office of the chief
medical officer
although that was before your time so
perhaps in the office of the
governmental Chief Scientific Advisor
and the dhsc or the cabinet office
that there was a need to refresh the
strategy that it was a a single strategy
dealing with
pandemic influenza and it was by then
self-evidently a little out of date and
there was no other strategy for
non-influenza pandemic in existence
um so I'm going to um
just go into one bit of Sir Humphrey
like language differential in government
refresh generally means update but it
doesn't mean any major shift
when you read this document now with the
benefits of having been through the
thought processes of unfortunately we've
had to be faced with during covid
it clearly needs a complete rethink it
doesn't need just a refresh and had
there been a refresh or for you to use
that term which is not what I
particularly like but I'm just using the
term that was used
um it would not in my view have
significantly changed in terms of its
philosophical or approach it might have
updated some bits around the around
legislation and bodies and so on but it
would not I think have been materially
different to what it is now and I think
what it needs is a rethink and I also
think alongside it and I've discussed
this with colleagues uh already I've
said we need to do this there needs to
be a separate equivalent uh thing for
non-influenza pandemics so I think
essentially there need to be two
documents
and that's a point of course which has
been put to those who actually are
responsible for the drafting of the
strategy within the dhsc and the cabinet
office
on the first point that you make Sir
Christopher
does it follow that even had the refresh
been
again I Paul could use anybody even had
the refresh been carried through
it wouldn't have led to a significant
difference in the United Kingdom's
ability to prepare for the the pandemic
that in fact ensued because it wouldn't
have led to the necessary radical change
of thinking that would have had a
practical impact on our preparedness
Arrangements that is my view right
can we come then to the doctrinal floor
to which you've just referred
in that strategy the one that might not
have been picked up in any event even
had there been a refresh
would you agree with the following
propositions
firstly
that there was in that strategy and
generally across government a
long-standing bias in favor of influenza
uh so I that statement is true for good
reason I don't think that means that
other things were not considered and the
reason for this is simply that we've had
many more influenza pandemics anyone
who's born after 1950 would have lived
through three of them
and therefore uh it is you we do have to
think about influenza separately I do
actually think that is in terms of
predictable risks it's the biggest
single predictable risk or what most
people think is the most likely thing is
something we have not predicted what uh
who calls disease X and it's thinking
around the ability to respond to the
unexpected the unpredicted that I think
that the separate strand of thinking
needs to occur
I think the phrase comes from your
predecessor Professor sir Professor Dame
Sally Davis that there is a long-selling
Pious bias is a state of factor as a
state of affairs
it may well be
that there was
good reason for that State of Affairs
and so far as the policy and the
guidance and strategy correctly
recognized other risks it just happened
to determine that they were of lesser
probability or lesser likelihood and
therefore they received less than 10
less attention but
there was was there not administratively
a general taking of the eye of the bull
in terms of
focusing on those other risks
less probable less likely as they were
and a general Trend towards focusing on
influenza
disproportionately to the
to the with the consequence that
other areas other risks other matters
were not sufficiently catered For
I I think I I would
um differentiate here between having
documents and having thinking
uh the um
if you think about nerve tag which
you've already talked about nerve tag
was explicitly designed to cover
non-influenza risks certainly my own
thinking is not in any way limited to
influenza I think I submitted as
evidence
talk I gave in Gresham College in 2018
just to prove it was not a post-hoc
rationalization there have been a number
of those and just make the point in most
of what I was talking about was not
influenza I think so I don't think it
would be correct to say that no one was
thinking about anything other than
influenza there were only documents
about influenza that's slightly
different and in reality when I looked
at this document at the beginning of the
covid pandemic
I did not feel the document gave me much
that was of any great use so the the
document and the thinking are in in
reality separate things
the question was predicated in fact on
on
on this aspect that what was there a
tendency administratively to become
overly focused on influenza so in fact
it wasn't designed to to elicit the
answer that there was a bias in terms of
your or the expert thinking in this area
but the system and prepared it as a
system
began to display a long-standing bias as
Professor Dame Sally Davis says in favor
of him I think that is true but I think
this goes back to
um a general point which I think has
been made by a lot of witnesses
that
because every pandemic is very different
and sometimes massively different from
its predecessors having plans is and
documents of this sort is actually not
generally the most useful way to deal
with it what you need to have is
capabilities and flexible capabilities
with uh which are backed up by resource
sufficient to be able to scale them up
and I think in a sense the danger in
government is that people feel the
document is written and therefore the
problem is solved and I absolutely do
not think that's the case I think it's
to do with do you have a range of
capabilities properly resourced with
people who know how to uh to operate
them and have them mandate to do so
and that brings me on to
the doctrinal issues well the the floor
strategic flaws two and three
in the plans but most notably the risk
assessment procedures
and and policies
was there in your view a failure to
appreciate properly
firstly that
because of the variables inherent in any
respiratory viral disease outbreak such
as levels of transmission high or
stuttering or transmission rate whether
short or long incubation periods whether
or not the virus would be asymptomatic
or not
there was a failure
to appreciate the risk sufficiently of
of a less likely
but no less catastrophic pathogenic
outbreak
plans simply didn't
openly address such issues transmission
incubation period
symptomatic infection yeah so I don't
think I mean I don't think it was a
essentially my view is there are two
separate issues that were were missing
the first in a way the one that I think
we really absolutely should have done
taken much more seriously was the
capability to scale up
and that is useful in virtually anything
the ability you know every pandemic
every epidemic the ability to diagnose
for example is essential and we had a
very good capacity to do a very small
amount of diagnosis really quickly and
we did not have the ability to scale up
and I could repeat that across multiple
other domains I'm going to bring you
back most importantly to this issue of
scanning up and capability okay fine but
just a lodge that I think that is very
important and then I think um there was
a strong intellectual appreciation that
you could have multiple other conditions
and if you'd asked any of the excellent
Public Health experts in UK HSA and
pheas it then was what are all the
different things that happened most of
them would have said there's a very wide
range what we didn't then do is go to
and say okay what are the building
blocks you're going to need for
different sorts of pandemic with
different variable levels of uh um both
route of transmission and mortality in
particular
and if I if I can illustrate that and I
am going to use lockdown because I think
it is so Central to the thinking of lots
of people who are thinking about this
inquiry if you look back over the last
several pandemics you certainly wouldn't
have used it in H1N1 in 2009 because it
was not a large enough impact on society
in any way to justify it would you just
made plain because it was a mild
influence correct you then going back to
the next one HIV a very serious thing
you would never have used it because it
was not used it would not worked at all
it that whole route of transmission was
different it wouldn't have worked
against plague it wouldn't have worked
against cholera it might have worked
against a the H1N1 to 1918 pandemic
possibly and that might have therefore
been Justified but I'm just making the
point that actually you have to be
extremely adaptable to the problem you
deal with but you also have to say well
if you go to the top range of mortality
how can we actually get that down and is
society prepared to pay the price to get
that down and I think that was the that
in a sense the leap of imagination not
just the UK but just internationally I
think we had not fully made because the
UK position was identical to almost all
of our neighbors to The Who and so on it
wasn't a uniquely UK position
Mr Christopher your answer of course
refers quite understandably to
capability
to the need to scale up and of course to
that
foundational triangle observation which
is that any plan for a pandemic must be
able to cater flexibly for
unexpected consequences or unexpected
pandemics
and and obviously mandatory quarantining
doesn't always work it all depends on
the nature of transmission of the
pathogenic outbreak
but my questions were designed to to ask
you about whether or not there was a
failure in the in the planning in the
the risk assessment process the the
actual systems that we have in place in
this country
to deal with the pandemic that the
planning the eprr structures
there was no
open
or extensive consideration of these
issues about transmission and the
variable and inherently variable aspects
of a pandemic or
asymptomatic infection or high
transmission rates turning at high
consequence infectious disease into a
full-blown Global pandemic they're just
not apparent on the face of all this
planning documentation and I think this
this illustrates a a failure in the way
we generally uh operate in government to
deal with emergencies which is to say we
need to have a plan for every
eventuality and if you can just pull off
the plan you can tick off all the things
you've got to do that's going to work
the problem is and pandemics is just one
example but a very very extreme one Kobe
demonstrated this actually what what
nature is going to give you to talk
about the hazards and threats are
different hazards it is going to be
completely different every time so what
you need to have is a building blocks of
lots of different capabilities and you
need to say actually we don't know what
problem we're going to face but what we
do know is we've got the capabilities to
face a whole range of different uh
possible outcomes and I think it's this
the system design is designed to focus
in on a plan based around a scenario
rather than to say multiple capabilities
that can be flexed to almost any
emergency in biological or a geophysical
or whatever space
but thirdly there does now need to be
and there is now a consideration of
multiple scenarios in a way which there
wasn't formally in all this planning
material
following the Royal Academy of
engineering review in particular with
which you're familiar
which specifically recommended that for
each risk a range of scenarios should be
generated to explore uncertainty and
possible additional planning
requirements so it's in essence the
point you make
a proper plan must have within it the
identification of a broader range of
scenarios to alert the system that
additional planning may be required and
additional steps may need to be taken
and that was the third strategic error
if you like wasn't it uh yes in my view
and then I think I'd add to that a
fourth which is to expose really clearly
to political leaders that there is a
choice in terms of resource
and that here is a one in fifty year
event do you wish to buy the insurance
for that one in 50-year event this is
how much it's going to cost and I think
that is really Central to this because I
think the danger is we respond to a
threat a newer perceived threat with a
new plan but with no new resource and
that very seldom tends to end in a good
way may I may we park resource at the
end of the list I'm that's obviously a
political issue
focusing continue to focus on on the
system
um is a fourth strategic
error that and and it's one that I know
you know that Mr Hancock particularly
has made reference in his witness
evidence to to this inquiry is that
because the reasonable worst case
scenario approach focused on the Worst
That Could realistically happen
and because everyone's Minds were
therefore focused on trying to deal with
the Worst That Could realistically
happen
insufficient thought was given to in
practice
until obviously covert was upon you
trying to prevent the worst from
happening at all
I I half agree uh with the distinguished
previous Secretary of State
I certainly agree
that we did not give sufficient thought
to what we could do to stop uh in its
tracks a pandemic on the scale of covid
or indeed any other pathogen that could
realistically go there
I do think on the other hand it is
sensible to have a plan for if
everything fails what are we going to do
we do still need to be able to say let's
go to the top of the range actually we
could end up with 750 000 people dying
where are we going to bury the bodies
where are we going to these are
important they may seem morbid but they
are practically important planning
things in this sense I do think a plan
is important but where I would
completely agree is that we do need to
actually start off and I think this is
brought out in Mr Hunt's uh evidence
yesterday there should be and actually
also Mr let wins all of them essentially
said we didn't we saw this huge problem
and we didn't say to the system well how
are we going to stop it and actually it
is senior ministers who have the
capacity to say to the system actually
are you absolutely right we can't go any
better than that we need to actually
address that so I think this is about
the interaction between the political uh
We've really got to do something serious
here I want to be absolutely good we
can't do any better and the scientific
and Technical okay well in response to
that challenge here here is your range
of options that they are going to cost
uh something and you need to understand
what that trade-off is and then you can
and that I think is where I think we
have not been successful could we've
just pause on the phone excuse I think
it may be that it's too much quieter yes
quite a morning for I I have out of the
corner of my eye tried to keep an eye
upon the the travails of our our
wonderful stenography I apologize mine
I'm for my fast speaking
because I said to another witness it's a
tendency I have too so I understand it's
very difficult to change your patterns
of speech
um but it would can we break there
Melody may I just put one final thoughts
just so crucify provided you speak
slowly I I hope I speak a little slur
so Christopher
you have then identified four broad I
would suggest strategic errors or flaws
in in the system none of these are
personal they're they're all of course
to do with the way in which the system
readied itself for a prospective
pandemic
the fifth is a matter that you you
touched upon earlier into which you you
made reference was there a a general
strategic failure to learn from the
experiences of certain East Asian
countries
who had dealt with SARS and MERS
and and to learn from their responses to
the particular characteristics of those
coronaviral outbreaks the learning to
which you referred earlier of course
relating to mass testing Mass contact
tracing mass self-isolation and
mandatory quarantine
well I think
certainly if we're talking about the
pre-pandemic the covid period yes I I
certainly think that we should do more
to learn from
approaches which are not the standard
European North American if I can
simplify approaches to things which tend
to dominate a lot of our thinking so I
certainly think we should be uh
communicating as much as we can with
other countries including in Southeast
Asia and East Asia which have
outstandingly good scientists who often
come at things with a very different
perspective however some of the very
specific learnings that people are raise
are in my view technically incorrect I
don't want to go through them in great
detail but for example you know I've
spoken to my colleagues in South Korea
about MERS
their principal problem was an issue of
Hospital transmission that's where most
of the transmission what the large part
of the transmission force of
transmission came from what that did
though is it made them think that they
had simply under invested in both
intellectually and financially public
health and they did so they completely
changed the way they were much more
systematic the same was true in Canada
for example after SARS exactly the same
issue a lot of the transitioners in
hospitals the numbers are small but the
impact was very substantial they changed
what they did and they re-thought their
whole approach and they reinvested in
public health
that is that that is a very very generic
learning it wasn't the this is a
coronavirus and therefore we can learn
from a coronavirus I think for a variety
of reasons I don't think it's probably
this is the right place to go into it's
very very long chain of logic but it is
reasonably solid about it I think that
it was much more the generic we need to
strengthen Public Health responses to
infections and take them very seriously
at the earliest possible stage and scale
rather than these particular learnings
we took away from this particular virus
so the generic the systemic improvements
rather than specific countermeasures for
example that's yes I mean there are some
exceptions but broadly that is my view
all right lady may we leave it there
certainly quarter two please
all right
thank you
I'm sorry if there was some confusion
about whether I was taking a short break
or lunch
Professor May return please now to the
the issue of maintaining capability
in your witness statement you make these
points that
as soon as the danger of a
pandemic or an epidemic has passed it's
in the nature of things that countries
start to dismantle whatever capacity
they put into place
probably at great speed and under
extreme pressure
and you make the further point that it's
simply not possible for any reasonable
or proper system to to maintain a full
standing capacity
to deal with a pandemic or prospective
pandemic
but also that the risk
of a future pandemic is an enduring one
it doesn't go away
so
you make the concluding point that
in order to respond in a measured
reasonable proportionate way
to Future challenges
there has to be the maintenance of some
basic capability that must be scaled up
in an emergency
how is that line to be drawn where does
one
draw the line in terms of
what those basic capacities are
How can any government
have a clear understanding of of what
capacities it must keep by way of a
minimum standing ability
well I think that there are firstly a a
group of technical capacities that we
have to keep at a potentially quite low
level but we need to have them so for
example we must have people who are
what's called entomologists who look at
uh insect and other vector-borne
diseases uh for humans they happen
rarely except for things like lime which
happen uh not as an epidemic but we need
to have that capacity because were we to
have such uh an outbreak in the UK we
need to be able to respond to it so
there are specific skills we need to
maintain across a whole range of
different disciplines and then what we
need to have is the ability to scale up
in the predictable areas which would
include things I've mentioned already
like diagnostic skills it might include
PPE protective equipment and a variety
of other areas and it's this scaling up
which in my view was the weakness that
was demonstrated during the early phase
in covid and I laid out to kind of five
stage in the witness statement I'm not
going to go through it in full a
five-stage process but the first three
stages were an initial technical
response to the small number of early
cases
which I think was done well and I think
the UK is well set up for a then a
scale-up phase and then the point where
the full capacity of the state is in
play which is a political decision
essentially but that scale up between
them uh needs to be uh to be possible
and that requires investment now how
much investment is a political question
but I think what we need to do is put to
political leaders who absolutely have to
make this decision
what is the level of risk that you think
we should be insuring for and this
should be explicit and I think we've not
necessarily always done that and said to
be said to our political leaders I speak
for society and must have the last word
this much additional risk mitigation
held in some form or another will reduce
the risk of a future pandemic or other
emergency but it will cost this much and
do you essentially wish to take that
insurance that I think we have not done
and I think we need to be a lot more
explicit about this
in effect
the choice
for future politicians or current or
future politicians for society and the
public
must be plainly identified so that that
choice is available to be exercised
exactly it may be exercise through
holding dual use facilities Maybe by
holding contracts with the private
sector right of ways it can be done but
it will have some implications and that
results will have to come from somewhere
else of course so there will be a choice
for people between having an insurance
against uh future events and for example
investing in immediate emergencies
pressures in the NHS during winter and
so on that is a choice and I think it
has to be made explicit
the first of the two areas of which
you've spoken the technical disciplines
is it in fact the position that in this
country we were blessed
and remain
um blessed by
the major scientific capacity
particularly the area of infectious
diseases which exists so in terms of
the acknowledged experts in the field
the strong academic centers the
expertise in government
technical capacity in public health
England and the NHS now ukhsa and the
basic applied research
our scientific structures were as these
things go relatively strong yes I think
I think
I don't think that's a kind of
jingoistic position I think most
International observers would say the UK
scientific response particularly on
research but in other areas as well was
very strong by International standards
or other areas people might be more
critical of but that I think is seemed
to be not perfect by any means but
certainly Strong by International
standards I think it's essential we're
keeping that to be clear and and
was that evident at the time of the
pandemic released and the Advent of the
pandemic by the the speed with which
diagnostic testing
was able to be developed by the various
studies and the the scientific work
which was put into place the the Sara
study the Vivaldi
study in relation to Care Homes the
covid-19 infection survey the the
recovery trials in relation to Dex uh
methazone and so on
on the scientific side of the response
to the pandemic
the United Kingdom
was in a relatively good position yes so
that's my judgment and I don't think
that's a particularly controversial
judge
so the issue then for this inquiry is
the scaling up the operational and
necessarily the political decision
making which has to underpin it for the
future exactly
is it important therefore to
to State openly that
as a as a system
the Country Must maintain a strong and
established
clinical public health and biomedical
research base so that in the event of
the next pandemic that scientific
support will continue to be available
that is absolutely my view and I think
people exaggerate the degree to which we
can predict what the next threat will be
and therefore we need to have a ability
to make a full spectrum response to a
whole variety of different threads
and that includes therefore scientific
Workforce scientific
research infrastructure
the flexibility
through studies through proper
scientific resource and so on to be able
to respond to the next pandemic exactly
all right
now finally just two aspects of your
technical report please
um you've covered many of the areas in
the course of your evidence and um
I'm sure you well you've you've
heard your technical report already
I want to address two threads in the in
in the report one firstly why is data
and the provision of data so important
to preparedness
if you think about the decisions that
were being taken uh both early in the
pandemic and subsequently all of them
rested on having fast and reliable data
and if you don't have that data and you
don't have it from around the country
with a representative group of the
population you're essentially driving in
the dark it's very very difficult to
work out what the right decisions are
and as I'm sure we will come in onto in
the next module this causes some
significant problems in the first part
of the response
it also the more data you have the more
exact your decisions can be the nearer
in a sense to what's the optimal outcome
because you're always trading off
different very significant risks between
things political leaders need to be
given data and you can also on that base
research studies on which you can then
devise the countermeasures the medical
countermeasures which will be the way
out of the pandemic in the end and one
of the key themes of the technical
report and indeed a lot of what I've
said elsewhere is that you move from
societal interventions which are by
definition crude and damaging but
they're all you have initially because
you don't have drugs you don't have
vaccines don't have Diagnostics and so
on you move over to a medical
intervention that that depends on
research and research depends on data so
that they are they are linked together
As You observe
the inquiry module 2 will be looking of
course at the provision of data that was
in place
um on the eve of the the pandemic and
what was available to decision makers
when they responded
particularly in in February March of
but the point goes beyond that
there have plenty been changes in the
supply and provision of data in the
United Kingdom
undoubtedly government processes for the
Assembly of data have changed and
improved as a result of the pandemic
is therefore the point to be taken that
it's vital to ensure that those systems
do not degrade in the future that the
higher levels at which data provision is
being maintained now must be continued
so I think there are two elements to
that I completely agree with the basis
of the question the first is a technical
one do we actually have the ability to
collect the data and then to knit it
together from different directions to
make an overall picture that's
absolutely essential that's largely a
resource and skill set question and then
it is very important that we take the
general public with us whose data this
is at the end of the day to make sure
that they feel comfortable that the way
that we've brought data together to
support decisions to support medical
science is in is in line with what they
would be expecting from their own data
and I think those two have to be kept in
Balance but occasionally I think we have
allowed ourselves to get overly
concerned with the risks of this and
therefore not make for not actually
bring together data that will be hugely
in the public interest to bring together
both to allow us to provide services now
and to provide science that will improve
public health and Medicine in the future
a second perhaps even more important
aspect of your technical report because
it comes in chapter two is the issue of
disparities
why are disparities in health
relevant to the issue of preparedness
the evidence so Christopher shows that
the government systems on preparedness
and the policy and the guidance and the
structures paid absolutely no regard to
disparities in health other than insofar
as there was an obvious reflection of
the fact that clinically some sectors of
the population because of comorbidities
would be worse off in the event of a
pandemic your report focuses to a very
large extent on the need to ensure that
disparities in health and in society are
addressed why must they be addressed in
the context of preparedness
one of the things that is striking and
repeated in every pandemic and epidemic
is that people living in areas of
disparity
suffer most from them the reasons for
that however vary so you know the
reasons that people in cholera epidemics
died in higher numbers is because of the
provision of poor water the reason that
people in uh some of the respiratory uh
pandemics of his history uh died was
because they were in crowded uh housing
conditions and so on and I'm making that
point because uh you you both need to
think about disparity as a whole but you
also need to think about what the causal
pathway is for each route of
transmission and for each pandemic as it
goes through but I think there's the one
final point I would like to make which
is
the best way you can deal with reducing
the risk of a pandemic to people living
in areas of disparity or living with
particular risks is to is to get on top
of the pandemic essentially that is the
most sure way of doing so and I think we
have to always remember that that's the
central plank on which everything else
is is based
finally in a
in a particularly
self-deprecating manner
stated in evidence that politicians
where in some significant regards
amateurs
and that there was a a case for training
of ministers and officials in crisis
management
is there anything that you'd like to say
on that topic
I I would absolutely not want to venture
to suggest any particular training for
our political leaders I think that much
of what they bring is the ability to ask
questions which in a sense people bring
because they're new to a field I think
one of the dangers in all areas of
expertise is you become snow blind you
don't realize the obvious question and
actually having political leaders who
come in from outside is one of the ways
in which they can produce radicalism and
I think so Oliver are sparing his
blushes as he's not here was a very good
example of that he did it in my view a
superb job for example during the West
African Ebola crisis in knitting things
together uh absolutely picked up on all
the issues I think however what is
helpful is for people to realize the
range of capabilities they have at their
disposal and therefore whilst I I you
know whilst that's entirely optional for
certainly political leaders that's their
choice I do think within government that
sometimes a of understanding of science
between emergencies and this goes back
to this between emergency and in an
emergency in an emergency everybody is
clamoring for science advice I've seen
this in every emergency I've ever seen
they are desperate to get this artist in
the room between emergencies you have to
kind of elbow your way in and so it's
the ability to actually engage all the
way through the system between
emergencies that I think is the big risk
people can pick things up very quickly
when they need to a very large
proportion of the British population now
know a lot more epidemiology than many
doctors probably did three years ago so
it's a you know people can people can
pick stuff up very quickly when they
need to what I think they need to do is
think about the range of issues between
emergencies which may in due course lead
us into problems between emergencies so
Christopher you are sadly profits in
your own land
I wouldn't go that far
thank you very much Milady there are a
number of questions under rule 10
from
covid-19 Brewery family suggestions
group thank you
[Music]
thank you my lady
good afternoons Christopher my name is
Alison Monroe and I ask questions this
afternoon on behalf of covered Breeze
families for justice
before
um the questions arise out of a guidance
document that you may or may not be
familiar with Sir Mark walport provided
the inquiry with a draft guidance for
sage on emerging infections diseases
which was produced between 2013 and
2017.
and perhaps if we could bring that
guidance up please it's inq triple zero
one four two one three nine
thank you and if we go to page two
we can see the the contents
of the document and then at page three
thank you at page three the purpose
so this document is intended to assist
the government Chief Scientific Advisor
and the scientific Advisory Group for
emergency Sage to provide timely
relevant scientific advice to the
cabinet office briefing rooms Cobra in
the event of an emergency involving a
non-influenza emerging or unidentified
infectious disease which might affect
the UK
now I don't need to take you through the
rest of that document for the purposes
of the questions but suffice to say Sir
Christopher within that document there
are definitions of risk
definitions of emergent infectious
diseases and at Pages for reference six
seven and eight
the guidance sets out key issues in
terms of the impact or potential impact
of emerging diseases on public on civil
society and on the economy
first question answer Christopher rather
long introduction did you know about
this guidance at the time that we're
concerned with in this inquiry
uh I didn't recall this guidance uh
during the
short period between the coming CMO and
the outbreak of the pandemic but I
suspect I may well have contributed in a
very in several previous iterations of
my role to the development of this draft
guidance I recognize kind of phrases I
probably would have put into it so I
think I am aware broadly but it's a
while since I've seen anything like this
and it's not I certainly hadn't seen the
final version in fact I'm not sure there
has been a final version of this yes
because it's the authorship and the date
of the the document I've said between
2013 and 2017 so as you said there are a
number of different versions of it
perhaps iterations of it
there were two there were two sorts of
document if I can just clarify the
documents like this which were to help
guide the sage process and make it
rapidly respond to a problem and then
when I was uh in an interim just interim
government Chief earning advisor between
smart warport who you heard from uh
yesterday answer battery van so you'll
hear from subsequently I helped to
add to that something we call Golden
hour documents which were documents
which allowed someone to deal with the
bones of a problem even before Sage had
met where you actually look at the key
issues scientifically so you can
actually inform discussions with
ministers
yes because in the guidance and again we
don't need to take you to the document
or have it up on the screen but Pages 8
9 and 10. set out a series of questions
for Cobra and certain responses or
advice that um could and should be given
um are you able to tell us then uh so
Christopher
um in terms of this particular guidance
how would it have been used by yourself
and what considerations to this guidance
would you have given particularly in
terms of informing any pandemic planning
and educating Frontline workers in
health or social care for example so
this document to be clear had a pretty
narrow specific purpose and this was to
help guide the setup for a sage were
there to be an emergency in this
situation so it was not designed for
Frontline workers it wasn't in fact
designed to have a wider utility this
kind of document was very narrowly to
help the government officer science to
have the most focused and effective
first few stage meetings this would be
particularly important if the government
is done advisor for example is working
an area outside his or her own field of
expertise I think the more they're in
their area of expertise the more they
would have felt comfortable in a sense
setting the agenda themselves
but as a guidance document by as its
name suggests it it provides you with
some advice and perhaps it's almost a
starting point for further discussion
further thinking exactly it's designed
as guidance but guidance to guide the
sage meeting not guidance for The Wider
uh generality
you've mentioned the golden hour
documents again turning back to Sir Mark
walport who said of this draft guidance
that it morphed into the current set of
golden hour documents used by go science
um
firstly can you just explain what what
what that is when when you talk about it
and when so so Mark talks about the
golden hour documents so uh the the
slightly clumsy phrasing actually
unfortunately is from me because I it
comes from sort of classic medical
emergency uh procedures where you say
you there's a golden hour in which you
can intervene very rapidly and in that
time you can have a very big impact and
the the Lacuna the Gap that I perceived
and others perceived was there was a
period between the point an emergency
arose and a point a sage had met when a
government Chief Scientific Advisor a
departmental cheese standard advisor CMO
or ever would be asked legitimate and
important questions by political leaders
and others to which they would have to
give answers at that time but in advance
of this age so the idea of it was to
give basically a kind of crash course in
a subject let us say a major earthquake
so that someone could actually go to
their first meetings with some degree of
confidence they had the various areas
covered thank you and I think you've in
that answer you've answered my next
question which was how was this these
golden hour documents used within your
specific role as chief medical officer
is anything else that you want to say
about that and how you would use it no
except I think to pay tribute to the um
the sage secretary secretariators from
gosans who not only manage the stage of
meetings but essentially provided the
Horizon scanning and the apparatus that
underpins what the government G sounding
advisor can do in an emergency
particularly in the earlier stages thank
you
um so Christopher my next question is
about emerging infectious diseases
um am I correct in saying that high
consequence infectious diseases fall
within the emerging infectious disease
category on the national risk register
so for example Ebola SARS Murs avian flu
are all examples of high consequence
infectious diseases
hcids some high consequence infectious
diseases are emerging diseases a few are
not and many emerging diseases are not
high consequence infectious diseases so
they're not synonymous but there is a
lot of overlap in some of the more
severe ones uh the ones like the ones
you mentioned
so my question is this Christopher um in
the guidance and this is at page five it
says that um
an emerging infectious disease could
potentially become pandemic and that
must be correct listen to you very
rarely very rarely
the author then goes on or authors
rather go on at page six of the guidance
to outline
firstly the most likely scenario and
then the worst reasonable worst case
scenario if we could perhaps have the
document back up and go to page six to
look at what's actually said there
um
so just looking at that box at the top
of page six Sir Christopher
um
are you familiar with what's written
there I am yeah
so they're starting again it's a
starting point for thinking and
discussion in this document looking at
scenarios and what potential action
could potentially be taken and also
looking at behavioral aspects as well
um
so you would accept would you not that
in relation to emerging infectious
diseases such as SARS
um
or a sars-like disease that was the most
likely scenario
within the uh narrow narrow-ish
definition of emerging infectious
diseases that were important enough that
they could have an impact on the UK
that's a lot of caveats because but in
that environment something like SARS
would be a very good example but if I
can just to explain why I've made that
distinction another emerging infectious
disease of very considerable
significance of zika virus we consider
this roughly over this time period we
thought this is a very serious emerging
infectious disease but because the
mosquito species that could pass this on
are not able to maintain themselves for
long periods in the UK at least at this
point in time
we thought this was a significant risk
globally in this particular case in
Brazil and this was in an olympic year
but it was not a significant risk in the
UK nor was it likely to become so and it
is quite important when you look at a
risk or a hazard that you make a
judgment is this a risk or a hazard in
one place or is it a risk or a hazard
that's likely to come to the UK this was
an example where actually the risk or
the risk in this case was not likely to
come to the UK and we made an important
professional judgment we did not need to
go beyond a certain point in our
planning on this because that would be
an inappropriate given the relatively
low risk in fact almost zero risk of a
significant epidemic of this infection
in the UK right well my final question
is about
um the where the emphasis lay
um in UK planning and just to put this
in context
um
with hcids
um there would need to be
in terms of the response an enhanced
response
there needs to be quite a specific
response which notice is based on the
fact that these infections can have a
very significant mortality if someone
catches them high high in terms of high
numbers
and in your evidence earlier this
afternoon it's just after half 12 I
think
um you were discussing long the
long-standing bias
for pandemic flu planning
um and you said I think that's true
having documents and plans are separate
things you need to have capabilities
backed up by Resources with capabilities
to scale up
um now with hcids and I think this again
hopefully you'll ex you'll agree with
this
in terms of airborne
hcids and the response responding to
them there have been some exercises such
as an ebola exercise wasn't there
yes I'm in Ebola just to be clear is
actually a touch-based disease it's not
Airborne or respiratory by root that's
an important point so where I sitting
next to someone who had Ebola right be
much less concerned than if it was an
Airborne or respiratory infection
well as a hcid is an hcid
um so there was a an ebola preparedness
surge capacity exercise wasn't there uh
I I if you tell me so I'm sure that is
true I can't recall it but I'm sure that
is true
um again again we don't need to bring it
up but for reference it is in the
documents at inq
four zeros
and the outcome of that surge capacity
exercise for this hcid
showed that there wasn't in fact
capacity to Surge it was a small amount
of five cases which would result in the
loss of 80 infectious beds so even on a
small scale for hcids it's going to be
it was going to be difficult wasn't it
to scale up and so the way that I would
like conceptualize this if I if I may is
that you have two extremely specialist
centers in the UK one in London one in
Newcastle which can manage the most
infectious and dangerous cases including
diseases we may never have come across
before around that there's a larger
group of centers that are specialists in
hcids which are in a sense still dealing
with very high risk infections but a
slightly lower level of risk but if he
ran out of beds with the first two then
you would move into the next area around
then around that are a group of
specialist infectious disease what's
called negative pressure rooms where the
air is sucked into the room and that's a
much larger number but these are still
specialist beds and then around that is
side rooms which are not Specialist or
don't have the right equipment what you
would do in an emergency is essentially
you go out from the center if you had an
hcid that was expanding in numbers at a
certain point you then move into what's
called cohorting where you take over an
entire Ward and we did this during covid
and you say everyone on this Ward is
going to is going to have this disease
and no one who hasn't got this disease
goes on to this Ward so there is a kind
of there's a mechanism for scaling out
each one of those it is at a slightly
lower level of expertise and at a
slightly lower level of protection
potentially maybe the first two are very
high high levels of expertise but in all
of those cases you always have to see
there's an opportunity to scale and this
is one of the things we've come back to
repeatedly you have to have plans to
scale and you have to have to work out
how you're going to do it that we're
going to have to leave it there I'm
afraid this family we've got an awful
lot to get through this afternoon my
lady yes I think in fact Sir Christopher
has answered my last question about
scaling out yeah thank you very much
thank you very much my lady thank you
sir Christopher
maybe that concludes the evidence of uh
Sir Christopher thank you very much
indeed Christopher extremely grateful
for all your help I was astonished and
sorry to hear about the abuse of you and
uh other colleagues it's wrong for so
many reasons but I do know how
distressing it can be so I hope that
people will think twice but of course
they never do do they before
committing themselves to distressing
acts unnecessarily there's so many
different ways to express different
opinions why do we have to have personal
abuse
thank you so much
[Applause]
this black girl my lazy man calls the
Patrick Valance please
[Applause]
thank you mate I invite you to take the
oath please
I just solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm declare and affirm
that the evidence I shall give but the
evidence I shall give shall be the truth
shall be the truth the whole truth the
whole truth and nothing but there's
nothing but the truth
thank you very much to Patrick
um and thank you for all of the
assistance that you've so far given to
this inquiry and for agreeing to come
and give evidence today I know that um
you will be called to give evidence
later on as well and you know as we have
made clear the permutations and the
limits of the evidence that that we're
going to ask you to give today our time
scale runs back 10 years from the onset
of the pandemic and so I'm not going to
ask you about decisions that were taken
during the course of the outbreak
please speak up please speak slowly and
speak into the microphone so that the
stenographer can hear for the transcript
I'm going to begin by setting out your
qualifications and career history so far
as it's relevant to this inquiry
you trained as a medical doctor and
practiced as a general physician in the
NHS in various hospitals in London and
you undertook research in cardiovascular
disease first at St George's Hospital
medical school and later at University
College London where you were appointed
first as a senior lecturer and then
professor of clinical pharmacology and
Medicine in 1995.
you let the division of medicine at UCL
from 2002 to 2006.
and during your time you were a
consultant physician at the UCL
hospitals
from 2006 until until 2018 you worked
for glaxo Smith Klein initially AS
Global head of drug Discovery and from
2012 AS Global head of research and
development where you oversaw the
discovery and development of many
medicines including antibiotics anti-hiv
drugs cancer treatments and drugs for
asthma you are an elected fellow of the
Royal College of Physicians the Academy
of Medical sciences and the Royal
Society and an honorary fellow of the
Royal Academy of engineering
from April of 2018 until March of this
year you held the post of government
Chief Scientific Advisor
and it's really Sir Patrick in that role
that we want your assistance at this
stage in the inquiry
one of the benefits of giving evidence
after summer walport and the last
witness Professor sir Chris Whitty is
that a lot of the explanatory evidence
of of your role as Government Chief
Scientific Advisor and indeed
explanatory evidence of some of the
scientific advisory groups has already
been received by my lady
but I would like to touch upon some
common features of the evidence that
both of those Witnesses have recently
given
in terms of your role as Government
Chief Scientific Advisor can you tell us
please Sir Patrick what you feel you
brought to the role any changes that you
made improvements that were brought to
bear during your time in that role and
also tell us how you saw your role
fitting in with the departmental
scientific advisors and whether or not
that part of the system is something
that could be improved well thank you
very much and um I'm very grateful to
given the opportunity to contribute to
this inquiry which is obviously
important for the future resilience of
the country
when I came to the role I took advice
before I came to it from a number of
people and I came to the conclusion that
getting the science system in government
truly embedded as part of government in
an everyday sense was important in other
words it shouldn't be something that's
off to one side that you just turn to
when you think you've got a specific
scientific problem
but it should be that science actually
is embedded in everyday thinking and
policy making and therefore having high
quality science advice systems would be
a crucial part of that and part of that
links to the need for every Department
to have a chief Scientific Advisor yes
those advisors sit in departments they
need to be part of the everyday activity
and the policy and operational
discussions taking place in those
departments so that they can bring in
science and science advice to areas
which perhaps a policy maker who's not
from a scientific background wouldn't
even think that science Technology
Innovation or engineering might have a
part to play
so one of the things that I set out to
do was to look at the science capability
across government and improve that
system
at the initial suggestion in a
discussion I have with sir Jeremy
Haywood who was in the cabinet secretary
and that project was undertaken with the
treasury and it was called science
capability review of realizing their
ambition through science and the idea
was to try and get more structure into
the system
so that we moved away from
individual
scientists being able to contribute if
somebody happened to ask them to one
where actually there was an established
process and system to allow advice to be
given on a regular basis and so I think
part of my Approach came from the fact
that I had run a very big organization
across the world and therefore worried
about things like sip making these
things systematic and you brought that
into force in November of 2019 didn't
you yes that was when the report was
published right
and um
on a I suppose a connected
issue would be
the danger of
um and this is relevant I think not only
to the scientific advisors within
departments but also members of some of
the scientific advisory groups which
we're going to come on to in a moment
that the danger of people moving
positions and losing the experience and
the knowledge from those positions how
do you say that the best way is to
capture that into and to maintain that
level of knowledge within the roles it
is a very big problem in government
people moving around and experience and
knowledge being lost
and ensuring that you have proper
departmental structural systems for
institutional Knowledge Management is
important and to make sure that
institutional memory can be captured so
one of the things that we spent quite a
lot of time on is trying to make sure
that that institutional memory is in
place that there are mechanisms that
don't rely on particular individuals in
order for this to happen and as a an
example which it may be a trivial
example but it's an important one I
think is things like papers it's one
thing to have a paper that has a date
when it was created it's quite a
different one to say actually I have a
paper which it says when this paper has
to be reviewed right and I think that's
really really important that you have
dates by which you say this must have
been reviewed by whatever otherwise it's
no longer a valid document so I think
they're process things like that which
need to be in place in order to ensure
institutional memory and continuity
we'll come on to it in a moment but you
will be aware of the evidence given this
morning by Sir Chris Whitey about the
United Kingdom influenza pandemic
preparedness strategy from 2011 which
was not given any sort of refresh or
review
um in the in the time that um passed
between its implementation and the
pandemic hitting and the fact that in
sir Chris whitty's view it didn't need a
refresh it needed an overhaul perhaps if
if that document had had within it
um a date by which it had to be properly
and fundamentally reviewed then then
that might have happened well it seems
to me that is good practice if you like
have a sell-by date on these things
which you must have looked at it and you
and you can't just roll it over you have
to have taken an action to have looked
at it and say I agree this is still
extend or no this needs to be changed
thank you
one of the issues we discussed with
Samar walport yesterday was
the important difference between
scientific advice policy advice and
political decision making
and the fact that
the
the role of a government Chief
Scientific Advisor it is not to provide
policy advice or to make decisions but
to give the scientific advice that is
requested is there an important
distinction between between those three
aspects of the roles very important and
I I don't think it's just to give the
science advice that's been requested
it's also the science advice that needs
to be given because if you just wait to
be asked
it again goes back to the Paradigm that
assumes that the people asking know what
the science advice needs to be so I
think science advice
is to pull evidence together and by the
way evidence of course changes the whole
nature of science is that it is
continuously changing and updating
itself and it is self-correcting so one
of the very important differences
between
um what happened in science where
science is actually quite like it when
they discover that something they
thought was true before isn't true
or isn't exactly as they thought it was
that is an exciting thing that of course
is not universally liked in other parts
of the world it's often seen as a U-turn
and or in other professions I was just
thinking about the legal professional
well I I can't comment on that
so I think science advice is about
bringing the evidence together and I've
laid out four things that I think are
important yes is the evidence base
adequate and if not what are you going
to do about it
the second is
um has the evidence base and your advice
been understood including the
uncertainties associated with it and
what might change those uncertainties
that's a very important part of this
because those uncertainties will change
the third and I think this is often
misunderstood
um particularly outside government is
has the advice it is the evidence being
presented in a way that's relevant to
policy because as a scientist you might
often be very excited by your latest
discovery
doesn't mean it's relevant to policies
you have to frame things in a way that
is sensible and usable by policy makers
and the fourth which I think is often
forgotten is can the science be used to
monitor the effects of any policy choice
the policy choice is not the end of the
process it should then be monitored to
see whether it's having the effect that
you thought it might have
one issue
issue raised yesterday in his evidence
and he described this as a as a two-way
street is the fact that
perhaps
perhaps or historically there has not
been as much
um
interaction is is perhaps not not the
best word to use but there hasn't been
an appetite on behalf of the scientists
to raise matters which uh have not been
requested by the government government
departments so there's been a a reactive
rather than a proactive involvement on
behalf of the scientific advisory groups
do you recognize that and if that is a
problem how do we going forwards ensure
that the scientists are are confident
enough to to raise things off their own
bat well I read some of the witness
statements from some of the Committees
yes um these are all Department of
Health committees and it's worth
remembering the the gcsa role goes
across every department and every area
of science so it's not it just so
happens I'm a doctor it's not that the
gcsa role is a medical one or indeed has
any particular focus on dhsc but I read
those comments and I saw that in some of
the Committees they were in fully
response mode according to the witness
statements I don't think that's correct
I I completely concur with what Chris
said and actually if you look at the
code of practice for science advisory
committees which is a document that we
submitted it says clearly that it should
be a mix of response mode I.E things at
the department which is no and things
that the experts wish to say or wish to
look at and I think that is important
and it's one of the reasons why if we
turn to the chief scientific advisors or
indeed the gcsa role they are fixed term
relatively short so three plus two for a
chief Scientific Advisor five uh for
gcsa
um
and they come from outside government
because you're bringing an outside in
perspective
and it's not a sort of long-term career
plan to be part of it so you don't have
the same sorts of
pressures and and career
um requirements and decisions that a
civil servant might normally have and I
think that is important because it is
about challenge as well as as well as
support and information provide
provision thank you
staying for a moment on the topic of
improvements you tell told us in your
witness statement paragraph 49 that that
you desired a high level of transparency
in terms of in particular the workings
of sage and
tell us please Sir Patrick why you think
that's important and how we can ensure
that that is something that's taken
forward well I believe that science
advice in government
particularly reports I don't mean every
single discussion has taken place but
scientific reports and outputs should be
made public and I think that's
beneficial for everybody it's beneficial
for policy makers actually it's often
not seen as that but it is beneficial
because it means the evidence base on
which a policy is going to be formed is
there for scrutiny is there for comment
is there for Challenge and actually is
often there for people to say okay I get
that now I can see why you've made that
policy Choice given the evidence that
you have so I think the science advice
should be public by default there will
be times when ministers need a
reasonable length of time to consider it
as their formulating policy that is a
reasonable and fair uh thing but I think
in principle the science advice unless
it's National Security related should
become public and
um I think one of the things we learned
early during the pandemic prior to the
pandemic the minutes and output from
Sage only published at the end of the
process of sage activation and quite
early on I was Keen to try and get the
papers out as soon as we could it took
longer than it should have done for that
to happen and and that that is I think a
regret and one that uh if you have the
processes sorted out in advance should
not be a problem in the future in other
words you should get those papers out as
quickly as you can and it's part of
normal scientific practice and and it's
the way in which science progresses
which is for other people to look at it
and say ah you might have gotten that a
bit wrong or that may be a little bit
different well what needs to happen then
in order for
in order for going forwards the um the
the well is it is it a change of policy
or is it a change of thinking or is it
the fact that somebody simply needs to
to to write down a series of rules which
are followed in the event of another
pandemic what needs to change two things
and the first is the rules need to be
laid out and that's been done
uh will be published as soon as possible
particularly the minutes the papers are
a bit more complicated because they come
from academics and others who have
control over those so so putting a
timeline on that's a bit more difficult
and what you don't want to do in my
opinion is to say everything you give us
is going to be in the public domain in
24 hours because they then won't give
you anything until it's a hundred
percent complete
understandably so I think that's one
thing and the second uh is
um the government office for science
needed to have a process for getting
papers out onto the website properly
searchable and constructed and that's
that's been sorted out so I think both
problems actually I see no reason why
this can't be the norm going forward
thank you except in National Security
System yes of course we're different
factors of life
please could we have on screen the sage
checkpoint review which is at six two
double four three
and if we go to page
four thank you and could we highlight
paragraph 22.
first of all Sir Patrick can you explain
to us what the sage checkpoint review is
um this was the initial review that I
asked for in early 2020 May 2020 from uh
um sir Adrian Smith to come in and speak
to a number of people in sage and other
parts of government to try and find out
what we were doing right what we were
doing wrong and how we might change it
as we were going along recognizing that
we were in for a long haul on this and
we wanted to get as much information and
feedback as we could thank you we can
see here science versus operational
questions
across policy customers and Sage
participants there was consensus that
the line between science advice and
advice on operational issues had
sometimes become blurred this led to
sage sometimes being asked to advise on
matters that were more operational in
scope for example in relation to
environmental transmission and the
science behind mitigating risks
now I don't want to ask you about what
took place during the course of the
pandemic but but just for to ask you to
explain whether in your view there is a
problem about
scientists being drawn into providing
advice outside of their level of
expertise and if there is how we can
plan so that that doesn't happen in the
future so some scientists in government
are there to provide operational science
advice and that's particularly true in
the public sector research
establishments and it would be true for
example in what was public health
England scientists they are there to
provide operational science um
advice and indeed to operationalize
science so that is entirely appropriate
I think what's important though is where
there where it is advised so it's either
from the chief Scientific Advisor or
from Sage or from other committees that
the evidence and the advice is separated
from the policy conclusions which must
be up to those who have to formulate
policy to put in place
there's a bit about training and
understanding that needs to take place
in that and there's also a bit about the
recipient of that because there were
several occasions when people would want
science advice on things that were
simply not possible to give that
science advice on because they were too
granular too specific too detailed and I
think I think that's a process of
learning
um it got better actually during the
pandemic and I don't want to stray too
much into what happened but there was
there was one thing that was important
which was an educational process of
those commissioning signs to try and
help them understand what were
appropriate science questions to ask and
which ones just were not going to be
answerable all right thank you you can
take that down please
in terms of
being better prepared
planning for both
those risks which we are able to
anticipate and those which we're not
able to anticipate but having in place
good systems flexible systems that are
able to to cope with the unexpected
talk at paragraph 20 46 in your witness
statement of something called rules of
the road
what do you mean by that can and how can
that help
well the rules of the road concept came
up during the production of the 100-day
mission
um which was a G7 project and that was
about trying to get
um vaccines Therapeutics and Diagnostics
in play within 100 days of identifying a
potential pandemic threat being declared
um and I'll come back to that perhaps
later but but the point here is that we
said well there are some things that you
don't need to wait and find out what the
infection is or what the problem is
before you can establish what you're
going to need to do so for example in
the 100-day mission it was on things
like sharing samples across borders
it was about sharing data without having
to go and renegotiate at the beginning
it was about rapid Finance mechanisms to
allow things to be done quickly these
things should swing into action
immediately without having to worry
about going through permissions and
processes and devise things in the heat
of the pandemic so the rules the road
concept is to identify the generic
issues that you know are going to be
there they might be legal they might be
ethical they might be political they
might be social and just say can we
please clear those so that we can
activate them immediately without having
to then redesign it or negotiate in the
middle of a pandemic
I know that my lady has given
provisional permission for bereaved
families for justice to to ask questions
on the issues of data and the topics of
how how that might be improved going
forwards but in terms of data collection
and data usage it is is is the rule the
rule of the road that that certainly
there can be
procedures put in place
now that are capable of being adapted to
to lots of different situations when
they arrive yes and I've argued and I
think it remains important that
for every risk on the National Security
risk register we should government
should go through and ask what are the
data that you know you're going to need
because it's going to give you
information who owns those data or in
other words where do they sit in the
organizations
how might those
flow somewhere in the state of an
emergency and where do they flow how do
you make them interoperable and who's
going to analyze them and those
questions are simple questions that can
actually be looked at in advance and
will throw up I think blocks that we
know exist and can be unblocked during
non-emergency times and it's very true
for pandemics and it's equally true for
other National risks as well I believe
thank you
what is your view of the interaction
between your role and that of the
scientific advisors within the devolved
administrations is it historically a
good relationship is it a close
relationship can it be in your opinion
improved at all uh well I have a very
good relationship with the chief
scientific advisors in Scotland and
Wales and increasingly now in Northern
Ireland where they've now got somebody
who's at least standing in for that role
and I work with the permanent sectors of
the devolved administrations to make
sure that they know that they do need to
have a government Chief Scientific
Advisor and have been on the
appointments panels for those uh those
roles
um the system obviously a bit different
in the devolved administrations in the
unlike for the um UK government where
we've got a chief Scientific Advisor in
every Department that's not the case in
the evolved in registrations but each
apart from Northern Ireland at the
moment does have a overall government
Chief Scientific Advisor
and that person is the one that I
interact with most of obvious reasons
because they have a job which covers the
government more broadly in in the
devolved administrations and and I meet
with them or met with them I should say
I'm no longer opposed met with them on a
regular basis as as I did with
departmental csas and also we agreed it
was useful to have a regular meeting of
just the divulge and me so we could talk
about things that were specific to
devolved administrations that we might
pick up together as a group and I think
that's that's what that worked pretty
well actually in terms of uh day-to-day
non-emergency situation for uh
interacting with the you know advisors
and I suppose one of the benefits of
that is that when something like the
pandemic hits you have already forged
relationships with those individuals and
there is a level of trust amongst you
which were you were you not um
were you not um concentrating on on on
making sure that there was joined up
thinking between all of the all of the
roles then that relationship wouldn't be
there uh personal relationships are
always important in these things and
that was a crucial one to to to get
right
um and they also and I the thing I
really like about the way that CSA
network has evolved is that subgroups
spontaneously fall so they formed say
actually we now know we we as a group of
three or four need to go away and do a
piece of work and that's what's happened
with the devault administration uh Chief
Scientific Advisor well they've done
that and formed a group I think there's
a specific question and I know it's come
up in some of the witness statements
about not the overall government Chief
scientific advisors but the individual
departmental uh Chief scientific
advisors in the devolved administrations
particularly in health and I have to say
um one of the uh one of the unexpected
consequences of getting a very
functioning CSA Network going is that
everyone wants to join it
and not everybody can because it'll
become overwhelmed and the reason that
we've stuck with um a single government
Chief Scientific Advisor from each of
the devolved administrations is a they
are the people who then can connect
their own csas in in those Nations uh
and and B it allows for for example the
health csas from the four nations to
join up as a group and I believe they've
now done that they've joined up as a
group I think it would be inappropriate
to start having all of those people in
the overall scientific Network otherwise
it's going to become very skewed by
health and topics we discussed ranged
from cyber security to climate to
biodiversity to Marine
laws and so on so I mean there are all
sorts of areas which is it's far away
from pandemics and and health
thank you before we move away to deal
with the role of the government Chief
Scientific Advisor in relation to the
National risk assessment I just want to
ask you on about a final matter which um
I know you have a certain level of
passion about and that's the prospect of
an academic center for preparation for
pandemic preparedness
why do you think that that is a good
idea well I think it's very very
important that we have a thriving
research base and and so Chris mentioned
that in his evidence and there's
something about bringing together a
critical mass of people who are
concerned with the same overall problem
of pandemic which I think is going to
provide
The Challenge and the independence and
the foresight into the system so I'm an
enthusiastic proponent of the idea of
creating a center for pandemic
preparedness
there are many different models that
people are looking at personally I would
favor something that was a sort of Hub
and spoke model where you had somewhere
where there was a physical base but then
you had many other universities involved
and that is a place where many different
disciplines could then come together and
actually that is a place where I think
things like economics could also be
considered along alongside epidemiology
and other areas because it would begin
to provide an insight into how you might
think about the sort of difficult
trade-offs that occur there so I think
um concentrating on properly funded well
structured pandemic preparedness Center
would be an advantageous thing for the
UK and would be an important part of how
you think about introducing really
informed integrated challenge into the
system
would that also have the capacity to to
soak up Behavioral Science something
along along those lines and as a as a
connected question do you think that
Behavioral Science Demands a place on a
full-time Advisory Board because we know
from the evidence of Sir Mark Walpole
yesterday that spy B was stood up for
the pandemic but has since then stood
down again uh a few a few things on this
first of all um the any Center for
pandemic preparers shouldn't just soak
up Behavioral Science behavior and
social science should be an absolutely
integral part of it and that's the whole
point it should be a multi-disciplinary
thing it's not one where I think
everyone is spending a hundred percent
of their time working on pandemics and
that's the beauty of it it would allow
an academic is a specialist in one thing
to say I want 10 of my time to be spent
in this and in doing so you would create
a critical mass so I think it's
fundamental I think it's worth noting
that I think every exercise that's
referred to in the documents had about
able scientists present at it so there's
been quite good representation spy B
which was set up I believe initially as
the name suggests for pandemic influenza
Behavioral Science was set up by dhsc
and stood down and we reactivated it
quickly during covid
um I'm not sure spy B is necessarily
what you'd have for ongoing Behavioral
Science input to other things and we
recently within the last year set up a
behavioral and social science for
emergencies group headed by one of the
csas who is a social scientist Jennifer
Rubin with the idea that that group
would look across National emergencies
and ask what is the social science
evidence base that's likely to be
required in different emergencies How
Could You commission research to try and
get that sorted out and what needs to be
done both inside and outside government
to try and get that right so I strongly
support the emergence of that group
thank you Ms Blackwell I think we if
that's convenient I think of course I
think come
getting signals right thank you I will
break then for we're back until we're
back at five plus three please thank you
sorry to break off
all right
foreign
[Applause]
thank you my lady so Patrick what is the
role of the government Chief Scientific
Advisor in relation to the creation of
the national risk assessment please
so the national uh risk assessment is
done Department by department so there's
a lead government department for each of
the areas and therefore the construction
of the content is done in in inside a
department and the challenge process for
the specific risk is done inside the
department the role of the government
Chief Scientific Advisor is to look
across at the methodology and ask are
there some anomalies or things that need
to be changed in order to get the
appropriate consistency across or indeed
other areas where we think that there's
a need for different types of approaches
given different types of risks so maybe
as an example my obviously my first
experience of one of these was soon
after I arrived and most of it was
entrained by the time I arrived but at
the end of it having pulled together the
CSA is to say are you all involved in
what's going on in your departments
because they should be not all of them
were so I had to sort of make sure they
knew what was going on and they were
actually linking in their inside the
department with the resilience teams
um and then to pull together the csas to
say when we look across other things
that we're now pulling up
sorry sir Patrick please continue are
there things that we're pulling up as as
anomalies or difficulties so I think
after the
risk assessment I wrote to
the Civil contingency sector area and
said there are a few things that we
picked up one of them was reasonable
worst case scenarios which you said
there doesn't seem to be a clear
consistent way of doing this across
departments and I think what was needed
was more of a sort of workshopping
approach in departments to really stress
test what they were putting forward as
their reasonable worst case scenarios a
second I'm sorry to interrupt you is
that the correspondence that you had
with Catherine yes yes he was head of
the CCS yes thank you very much sorry
please continue uh the second was around
interdependencies and concurrent risks
where we thought that looking at
everything completely separately doesn't
allow you to look at that properly
a third area was that I we felt that
there ought to be a way of not only
looking at expert Challenge in a
departmental sense but then to look at
expert challenge across the whole thing
and that might require external and
different types of groups to do that so
we suggested that that could happen and
the
um CSA Network could help provide names
and and support that that uh that
process and the final thing was that I
felt that ministers needed to really
understand what risks it was that they
were living with you know what was it
that they were actually agreeing to when
they did this now the process for
actually approving the uh National
Security risk assessment is through the
National Security Council and the
National Security Council then goes to
ministers and ministers sign it off
um and so that's really the role of the
gcsa is that sort of methodological look
across to make sure that there are
improvements and that led that that
feedback led to the commissioning of the
Royal Academy of engineering to produce
what I think is a very good report which
outlines
um some areas that could definitely be
improved on yes and just pausing and
dealing with the report that was
commissioned in January of 2021 yes and
within that report is a recommendation
that a spectrum of scenarios are
considered we'll come to that in a
moment but but just
remaining with the 2019 National risk
assessment the inquiry has already heard
evidence and and looked at the
assessment as it related to pandemic
influenza and the reasonable worst case
scenario involved up to 800 000 deaths
my lady
um a very eagle-eyed member of the
public has been in contact with the
inquiry to say that when I was examining
the former Prime Minister David Cameron
earlier this week I referred to 800
deaths rather than 800 000 deaths so can
I please make it clear that it was 800
000 deaths thankfully I don't think it
misled Mr Cameron but uh it didn't
mislead me either I'm glad to hear that
um
sir Chris witty earlier today was asked
about the
potential problem with the reasonable
worst case scenario system in that it
encourages
people to look at the situation wants
that reasonable worst case scenario has
happened and ignores the prior stage of
prevention do you acknowledge that
problem and if it is a problem what's
the solution
um I'm not sure well I absolutely
acknowledge that that's a reality that
there is less tension paid on that than
should be I don't know whether it's the
reasonable worst case scenario that
makes that happen or not I just can't
comment on that but I do think and that
was in my letter to Catherine and as
they went to the
um Foundation of why the Academy of
engineering was asked to look at this
that scenarios are important and looking
at different approaches to the real
world uh reasonable worst case scenario
is quite an important thing because if
you don't have consistency and it's
worth reflecting that of course the risk
assessment process has a mixture of
likelihood and impact yes which I think
is problematic because you then multiply
those two things to end up in a position
and
um the reason I think that's difficult
is people then associate funding with
where you end up
on that how so well because the higher
your joint score the easier it is to use
that as a lever to try and ask treasury
therefore you need more funding and that
may not be an appropriate way to view
this at all and so I think impact is
incredibly important and I fully endorse
the
um suggestion of the Academy of
engineering the impact is the thing that
should be focused on it's worth knowing
the likelihood but in the end events are
binary they either happen or they don't
have yeah you will remember the evidence
of Sir Mark Waldport earlier this week
who talked I think of the uh and also
sir Oliver letwin who spoke of the Black
Swan event that incident that is is not
particularly likely but when it happens
it is catastrophic and that those risks
shouldn't be missed
I think that's right I mean what you
then do about those risks and how much
effort and money you want to put on it
is a ministerial decision yeah and it's
important in that context actually that
a lot of this and I say this in my
statement
there's some analogies with preparing
for pandemic and other risks but I'll
stick with pandemics to the question of
whether you want an army or not
you need an Army in a country and you
don't turn around after 20 years and say
what a waste of money that was we
haven't had a war
yeah and I think it's the same thing you
know which are the risks you want to
make sure that you are properly enabled
to deal with
and I agree with the point that uh so
Chris made this is about capabilities
it's not about trying to end up with
highly specific responses in the back
pocket already for every single
eventuality that's not possible but
there are generic capabilities which are
important across the piece
and he spoke also a flexible
capabilities backed up by resources so
that if necessary scaling up is capable
of of happening at a short notice I
think scaling up is really really
important and I want to raise a couple
of points which I don't think have been
raised one is that industry is really
important and so one of the resilience
features for a country is which
Industries you've got that will enable
you to do it so
we were fortunate in some areas such as
vaccines and pharmaceuticals that we've
got a big sector that was able to
contribute to the scaling up I mean
making a vaccine isn't just what you do
in the laboratory it's the ability to
turn it into millions and millions of
doses
and we did not have a Diagnostics
industry of any scale in the UK which
made scaling up of Diagnostics much more
difficult and Germany has big
Diagnostics industry and did very well
on that so I think as part of resilience
planning it's quite important to look at
the question of industrial base in the
country as well and ask what needs to be
done to make sure that industrial base
is in a position and is properly linked
into the processes and the relevant
organizations
in terms of
vaccines then using that by way of an
example
um Dame Kate Bingham has expressed her
concern that it since the pandemic has
slowed down and and we've come out of
the emergency phase if I can use that
expression at the vaccine's task force
has been stood down do you think that
that is a problem do you think that
there should be an ongoing capability in
terms of vaccine production and and if
so it is that simply a political matter
or is that something which science can
help with well I started the vaccines
task force and brought Kate in for a
very specific reason which is we had a
very clear need to get things done in a
very direct way and she did it
brilliantly
um but that that need was obviously not
the same as the need now so I don't
think the model that we set up for the
vaccines task force in 2020 is one that
you necessarily need now
but is there a need for a focus on
vaccines for resilience absolutely so at
the beginning of 2020
when we started looking at vaccines in
January 2020 it was obvious that the
industrial vaccine base in the UK had
pretty much gone
not the they were simple still research
but the industrial base and I don't
think that was an active decision it was
what I call benign neglect with a very
significant consequence and so that had
to be reactivated quickly as a part of
that I think
um
the con the focus on vaccines then needs
to be embedded in what you do in
everyday practice and this is part of
the 100-day mission principle don't
dream that you can have a vaccine
Factory sitting there waiting for a
pandemic it's going to be staffed by
people who don't know how to make
vaccines
you need everyday activities that you
can then scale quickly and that I think
is a part of resilience that needs to be
really thought through very carefully
what are the everyday things and so for
Diagnostics if I take that as an example
the more the NHS use routine
click near patient rapid Diagnostics the
more you have an industry the more
you're able to scale that for pandemic
preparedness
is it a political decision
to ask well does the country want
the insurance of had it having a
standing capability in terms of the
strong scientific advice that secrety
spoke of being
incredibly good by International
standards
in terms of having a scalable
vaccine development in terms of other
types of medical procedures and and
interventions that might be required in
the event of a pandemic
that insurance policy something in your
view Sir Patrick that that really needs
to be grappled with at a political level
yes it's a political question and and
it's an important one that also links to
behaviors and culture which I think uh
sort of a let win touched on if
if I give a very specific example when
we set up the vaccine's task force
it was very very possible even likely
that it would fail
and at the end of it of course it was a
great success and the National Audit
office wrote a report saying what a
great success it was if it had failed
the national office I suspect would have
written a report saying what an
outrageous waste of public money the
whole thing was and yet both things were
totally possible and so there is an
inherent reluctance to spend money in
things which then might fail and look
like a disastrous misuse of public money
so I think we need to be much more
explicit about why spending public money
is important for certain things even if
that then turns out not to be what's
needed or used in fact it's picked up in
the Heinen report yes um in relation to
the 2009
thank you
I think it follows from the evidence
that you've given to the inquiry today
that you would also agree with sir Chris
witty on this topic
that although it's important to have
up-to-date and relevant documents such
as the influenza pandemic preparedness
strategy and perhaps even have a a
strategy along the same lines for
emerging infectious diseases
documentation only takes you so far and
what has been set out by both of you
about the flexible capabilities in in
Practical aspects of preparedness is is
really where the importance lies very
very important and I think whiteel loves
a report on a letter and and it's about
moving from that to a practical what's
the plan to actually do something about
this which is incredibly important
requires ministerial oversight and drive
to make things happen and very often
requires very clear single point
accountability otherwise things get
diffuse and don't happen yeah thank you
finally
um I'd just like to ask you about
the importance of identifying
those with health inequalities in the
planning and preparation for
pandemics and the like how can that best
be done
given that as the Chris witty explained
earlier today
one has to perhaps consider the causal
pathway of a pandemic to identify
who it's heading for
most forcefully I mean there is a
terrible terrible truth and
um
it's something that we all need to
reflect on which is that all pandemics
feed off inequality and drive inequality
that's the way they behave and that is a
tragedy that needs to be understood
and is relevant of course to the many
people who suffered during during covid
that needs to be built into the thinking
the thought process right at the outset
of course the issues of inequality are
very Broad and highly political across
all sorts of areas but the fact is it
does it is what drives um problems in in
pandemics and therefore one needs to be
extremely aware of that at the beginning
and one of the things when I look back
at the science advice we did pick up on
it but I would like it to be embedded
right from day one it needs to be one of
those questions on the first stage you
know what are the issues around the
inequality that you should be thinking
about now in terms of science advice
others need to think about it in terms
of operational planning and it's
relevant also to your question about
Behavioral Science I mean one of the big
questions is around communication
engagement with
marginalized communities and that needs
to be thought about in advance I hope
it's one of the things that the
behavioral and social science group of
emergencies will be thinking about now
as they think about what research and
other things can be put in place now
that could help inform people
thank you sir Patrick my lady as I have
already indicated provisional permission
has been given to covid bereaved
families for justice to ask questions on
the issue of data may that be done
please certainly thank you
thank you milady
uh good afternoon Sir Sir Patrick I ask
questions on behalf of covid bereaved
families for justice which represents
families across the UK
um
as has already been prefigured I want to
ask you a few questions if I may about
data and I think I can take it shortly
because you've already touched on this
in your evidence
um so Chris Whitty described the
importance of data in this context this
afternoon and I take it that you would
agree with his characterization of the
importance of data
and it's in my my statement it is
crucial it is
um would you agree that the importance
that importance that we've just agreed
on
um of the data in pandemic response was
something that was well known in the
scientific Community prior to covert
19's emergence yeah I don't think you
would have found anybody who said data
is not going to be relevant to any any
response I think yes data is important I
think it's well understood across
government that data are important for
decision making yeah
yeah
um now we understand from your statement
and again
um so Chris witty touched on this that
issues with data led to significant
problems in the early stages of the
pandemic didn't they
there was a pulsity of data which meant
that I'd say this in my statement that
there's many occasions it meant that um
you were flying more blind than you
would wish to
and those are questions
um for another module but the
fundamental point is that being able to
gather basic data such as how many
people are in hospital how many people
are in intensive care that was necessary
wasn't it to understand the spread of
the disease and to evaluate which
individuals might be most at risk from
the disease would you agree with that
yes
no and just one other thing I may I
think the the
um ons survey that we got in place was
another way of doing that and it would
be very very important to get those
things set up early
yes and I think you say in your
statement that systems were put in place
during the course of the response to the
pandemic but some of those had to be
started from scratch I think is the
phrase that you use and that's clearly
um not the situation that anyone would
would wish for would that be right
and now you've told us this afternoon at
Sir Patrick about the simple questions
that that in your view need to be asked
about data so just to to recap they are
what are the data we need
who owns them how can they be collected
how can they be shared are the systems
for doing that sharing interoperable so
do they speak to one another
and who's going to analyze the data have
I summarized those accurately thank you
now could we describe that those
collection of questions as a data
strategy
very high level I'm sure there are data
experts who would want to add much more
to that but I think in principle those
are the components yeah
and as you've said those are areas each
each of those questions should be
considered and resolved in advance of an
emergency yes
strategy as I've called it perhaps you
wouldn't but those collection of
questions that consideration of the
importance of data wasn't in place
before covid-19 to address a pandemic
was it I don't think it can have been
because that was not uh how it worked
and so I don't think the practicalities
so it's interesting because I think if
you'd ask people is that what you need
before the pandemic everyone would have
said yes and I'm sure that's fine the
reality was it wasn't fine and there
weren't systems that allowed that to
happen so practically operationally that
was not in place
and it should have been shouldn't it Sir
Patrick given what was known about the
importance of data in this context well
I think it should have been for all
sorts of reasons including it's very
important for running Healthcare systems
and so on so I think in general it was
an important set I think some of the
interoperability with other data sets
perhaps it wasn't so obvious that that
needed to be in place at the beginning
um and perhaps it wasn't a driving need
to have that in the in place at the
beginning but I think the basic bits yes
you would expect that to be in place the
core fundamental vets of Health Data
those should have been in place
beforehand
and just finally on this so Patrick if I
may you told us this afternoon I think
that you've argued that these questions
should be addressed for each risk on the
national risk register is that right yes
I suggested to be practical that they
should take the top 10 or 15 and do it
there to make sure that we knew how to
do it and then work through the rest
yeah and
of the argument that you made prior to
you leaving well I know I know it's been
understood and and that people accept
that this is what needs to be done there
is now something called the national
situation Center has been put in place
in central government which is a big
data center to be able to analyze data
and input data from many different
sources and there are data scientists in
that group as well so that is a very
very good start to this and I also know
that the chief statistician Ian diamond
and I spoke about this a lot and uh he
is looking at which Data Systems and
flows can be used to get this right so I
think there is action against it in
terms of a capability level I don't
think it's gone down to risk by risk yet
trick thank you lady thank you very much
that completes uh Sir Patrick balances
evidence thank you very much indeed to
Patrick you've been extremely helpful as
indeed was your obviously close
colleagues of Chris Whitley thank you
both very much indeed thank you
thank you my lady I'm being asked to
invite you to take a five minute break
whilst we arrange things for the next
witness please certainly I'll be back in
five minutes
will rise
my lady the next witness and indeed this
week's Final witness is Dr Jim mcmenaman
may he be sworn please
I'm so sorry
I don't think you're meant to give
evidence
let's try again
swear by almighty God that the evidence
I shall give that the evidence I shall
give shall be the truth shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth nothing but the truth thank
you
Dr mcmenamin thank you for the
assistance that you've given to the
inquiry so far you've provided a witness
statement and I know that you are
familiar with the corporate witness
statement as well from public health
Scotland and thank you for coming to
give your evidence to the inquiry today
please keep your voice up speak into the
microphones so that the stenographer can
hear you for the transcript
if you need a break at any time just ask
I'm going to begin by setting out your
career history so far as it's relevant
to the inquiry you are a medical doctor
with a masters in public health and
honorary clinical senior lecturer at the
school of health and wellbeing at the
University of Glasgow you were appointed
as a consultant epidemiologist to the
Scottish Center for infection and
environmental health in 2003 you were
then interim Clinical Director and
strategic lead for the respiratory viral
team within HPS and you are now the head
of infection service and the Strategic
incident director for covid-19 at Public
Health Scotland is that all right thank
you and one extra thing that I was the
chair for the three years of the
national Incident Management team in
Scotland thank you for the for the three
years involving covert 19. that's
correct thank you very much well it's
it's your evidence prior to that that
we're interested in today in module one
and I'm going to begin if I may by
using you to set out the history and
structure of Scotland's Public Health
bodies
as you tell us in your statement Dr
mcmenamin Public Health Scotland Works
to protect and improve the health of
people in Scotland and to reduce Health
inequalities
it became a legal entity on the 7th of
December of 2019 and came into operation
on the 1st of April 2020 and we'll come
back to that in a moment but that means
that in relation to the time to which
this module relates the national
leadership for protecting the Scottish
public from infectious diseases and
environmental hazards was the remit of
Health protection Scotland or HPS which
was part of the NHS National Services
Scotland is that right yes that's
correct
HPS LED on preparing for high
consequence infectious diseases
epidemics and pandemics and National
Services Scotland LED on preparation for
General civil emergencies and whole
systems civil emergencies is that right
yes that's correct thank you
you explain in your witness statement
that public health Scotland brought
together three Legacy bodies
Health protection Scotland Information
Services Division and NHS Health
Scotland so taking those three bodies in
turn if we may
HPS can trace its history back to 1969
and the creation of the communicable
diseases Scotland unit which was a
specialist unit tasked with conducting
surveillance of communicable infections
is that right yes yes and the
communicable diseases Scotland unit then
evolved absorbing and expanding its
remit to include helping protect uh the
public from non-infectious environmental
threats to health
and at one point the unit was renamed
the Scottish Center for infection and
environmental health and it then became
Health protection Scotland in 2005.
that's a Whistle Stop tour of the
history of Public Health in Scotland
but
Health protection Scotland was
responsible for providing health
information together with the
information Services Division and
National Health Service Health Scotland
was Scotland's National Health
Improvement agency
um
we have additional information about
this in the public health Scotland
corporate statement my lady
explaining that the work of National
Health National Health Scotland focused
on what could be done to improve Public
Health in Scotland and to reduce
What was seen as unfair and avoidable
health inequalities and is that work
very much still in progress
certainly very much so it's at the
center of everything that our
organization Public Health Scotland has
been set up to address thank you
Public Health
reform that began in 2015
with the public health review and as
we've already made mention was delivered
up to and including 2020 through the
public health reform program
are you able please Dr mcmenaman to
explain why it was concluded that public
health Scotland ought to be created and
was created when when that happened
thank you
um
over time there had certainly been a
very significant number of infection
challenges
um and information challenges in the
community
um from the perspective of inequalities
um earlier in proceedings we've had
heard testimony from experts on just
what the impact has been of those
inequalities
the purposeful bringing together of the
three organizations was to try and put
inequalities at the center of everything
that we do to improve healthy well-being
in the population
and that that very
um purposeful attempt then was to bring
together the relative strengths of each
of those organizations to try and assist
in that process if you like and to have
some Synergy between each of those to
make sure that nothing was falling
between the stones so do you see there
being a benefit of having a single
unified public health agency very much
so
what about the timing of it Dr mcmenaman
um why was public health Scotland made
operational in April of 2020 given as we
know that that was really a month or two
after the the covid-19 pandemic had hit
it's certainly unfortunate timing
um
but nonetheless something which had been
well scheduled and was very supported by
all of the territorial NHS boards and
the other boards in Scotland and by
Scottish government and also by
um kosler because this new organization
was to be one in which it was jointly
sponsored by
I am the chief officers of each of the
local authorities and um by Scottish
government so this signaled
um
approach where we were going to be
coming into being became and part of the
legal framework in December 2019 and
then we came into being on that April
2020 and that was as smooth as smooth as
we can make it transition where our NSS
National Services Scotland colleagues
assisted us all the way through and as
we became this new organization rather
than the 100 or so people that we might
have had at the start of this to try and
deal with things we now had access to
more than a thousand Personnel to be
able to help us in dealing with that so
in terms of the timing of it it was
something that had been in the planning
for several years
you mentioned costler that's the
convention of Scottish local authorities
isn't it
what was the right the rationale for and
the effect of Public Health Scotland's
accountability to both national and
local government
well this again was a a new bit of
innovative thinking where we were trying
to ensure that no matter what we did it
was to enable the health of the
population at a local level to be best
assisted within the combined efforts of
the new organization
thank you
some questions now about funding
um
you tell us in your witness statement
that public health Scotland's opening
budget and Staffing levels were in your
view not sufficient for the organization
to be able to deliver Health protection
in a response that was required when the
pandemic hit
is is that does that remain your view
and and explain to us please Dr
mcmenamin why you hold that view
yes
um in this instance the the particular
thrust that we had here was that um we
had to have a funding that was adequate
but flexible how do we make sure that
any ring for anything that we have
um didn't get in the way of what we
needed to do within the new organization
now I understand that
um
Financial
rules and regulations are essential
within our National Health Service
organization to make sure that we
demonstrate value for money in
everything that we do
but nonetheless it becomes important
that we're able to have flexibility in
how we can best
utilize that funding available to us but
there's one important caveat to that
and that for that funding and which was
you will see from our statement
submissions was funding in a a
pre-pandemic setting it was something
which was felt to be adequate for a
pandemic as we move into that that
flexibility and that we then would like
to have is something which becomes much
much
and more attractive to allow a speed of
response yeah
thank you may we have on screen please
document 101052
this is a document that we can see from
the bottom right hand corner was created
in December of 2006.
and it's Health protection Scotland's
Health protection framework for the
response to an influenza pandemic in
Scotland
we can see from the first two paragraphs
that this is indeed a document devoted
to pandemic influenza rather than any
other type of pandemic
Dr mcmenamin why did this framework
Focus only on influenza as opposed to
any other type of pandemic and how
if you can explain to us how did that in
any way hamper the situation
this document was produced before what
has been called the the Swain and flu
pandemic yes to 2009 yes
um it was at the time what we could see
was the likeliest issue to come and
challenge us so from that perspective it
was very deliberately focused on a
response to pandemic influenza in which
we on a UK basis were working
collaboratively to deal with that
all right let's look please if we can at
page seven of this document
and we can see that the aims of the
health protection framework is to
provide a tactical framework for health
protection response
to put the health protection framework
for the response to an influenza
pandemic in Scotland in the context of
the overarching national Arrangements
laid out in the UK Health Department's
influencer pandemic contingent
contingency plan the health Protection
Agency pandemic influenza plan and the
HPS emergency response plan just pausing
there
this of course predated the United
Kingdom influenza pandemic strategy
which we know was created in 2011 and
the inquiry has heard from several
sources that despite certainly best
efforts
at a time close to the pandemic hitting
it was never updated are you able to
tell us whether this older document
created as it was in 2006 was ever
updated to attempt to
um
give more
timely advice to Scotland on pandemic
influenza
thank you
um
it was never updated but the reason why
that was never updated
was that as you've outlined we then had
a pandemic of Swain influenza there was
a UK discussion about how we would best
learn the lessons
and and adult recommendations from the
learning lessons that we collectively
had
that meant that there was a a deliberate
attempt to have a coordinated UK
approach to how we deal with things
right and although at the time that we
did ask
um our Scottish government colleagues
about whether they would like this to be
Revisited and the clear indication that
we had at the time was that we would be
using a UK approach to deal with this
right so
moving up ahead from 2006 swine flu hits
in 2009
the UK government commissioned the Hein
review which indeed led to the strategy
being created in 2011.
once that was in place did the UK
strategy replace this older document or
did they sit alongside each other don't
say that it replaced
um things because we were then working
to a UK approach that was coordinated
thank you can we take that down please
and replace it with document
147859 which is an interim report from
the health protection stock take working
group
and we see that the date of that is July
of of 2011. do you know as a matter of
fact whether or not this came into Force
before or after the UK strategy
I'm quite sure because of the relative
dates of when things were produced again
whether the reports were
um synchronous or not
this was a working group
in 2005 which I think had led to the
2006 strategy that we've just looked at
and to ensure that they were still fit
for purpose is that right yes and this
interim report contains a series of
recommendations could we go to page 46
please
[Applause]
thank you we can move through this quite
quickly but the recommendations relate
firstly to capacity and resilience if we
can scroll down please
roles and responsibilities
priorities and outcomes
governance
and consistency
thank you
this was an interim report
the final report which we can put up
please at 147828
thank you and can we go to page 44
please
and we thank you very much sets out in
fact if we can can we go up to the
previous page so that we can see what
the columns
there we are
on the left hand side
I think we have the recommendations set
out and then the next column along going
from left to right we can see whether
the recommendation has made it into the
final report from the interim report
um
at the bottom at number 34 page 42 we
can see interchange should be arranged
between staff of HPS and NHS boards and
other activities considered to
strengthen relationships and engender
mutual respect and to help soften
existing boundaries this should include
a wide range of activities including
joint learning sessions joint training
and web-based initiatives now if we move
across we we only see that that
recommendation was in the interim report
but then on the the right hand column we
have these words
mhpn with the support of NHS boards and
HPS can you explain to us firstly if if
you know why this recommendation didn't
make it into the final report and what
is meant by by the um by the bodies in
the final column okay perhaps in reverse
order okay um the MHP and the I guess
here is a managed sales protection
Network what and ultimately it came out
of that was the score to sales
protection Network and obligate network
of stakeholders coming together who were
mutually working with each other
including local authorities to ensure
that we had addressed all of the
challenges presented with unhealth
protection so managed health
but that organization was working with
the support of the NHS boards and HPS
so does that mean that because those
systems were already in place that
recommendation didn't need to be taken
forward to the final report is that how
it worked well for for many of these
things that we were taking them Beyond
right because as I just suggested
that local authorities were known to
become part and parcel of what we're
trying to do to make sure that local
delivery was addressed
thank you can we go to
pay and highlight the
entry under roles and responsibilities
here we can see there is a need to
improve communication between HPS and
NHS boards interchange should be
arranged between stuff in both
directions and other activities
considered to strengthen relationships
and and gender mutual respect and to
help soften existing boundaries this
should include a wide range of
activities including joint learning
sessions joint training and web-based
initiatives
you can see on the right hand side the
assessment is that the managed health
protection network is of course designed
to help achieve a sense of integration
between all parts of a service and
should therefore be expected to serve a
function of improving relationships and
communication however our recommendation
on interchange and other activities
should stand so this is how it appears
in in the table
is the impression being created Dr
mcmenamin that there was a a difficulty
perceived in terms of relationships
between these bodies and and if so how
was that manifesting itself and and what
was the proposed solution in order to
engender better relationships
I think that the principal thing here
that we were trying to address was the
leveling up right to try and ensure that
um experience at National level and at a
local level was interchangeable that we
could then see and learn from each other
um the Scottish Health protection
Network and began it to have that
purpose by having that sharing of of
learning and experience and across the
all of the health protection functions
within Scotland and would you say that
following on from this final report
things did begin to improve
I think that um it certainly true that
they were much improved as a consequence
of the success of the Scottish Health
protection Network that's not to say
that are not continuing issues that
um we have uh had further effort to try
and overcome all right thank you very
much we can take that down now
um
concentrating For a Moment On The Wider
program of Health protection reform in
Scotland you tell us in your witness
statement that the creation of Public
Health Scotland was indeed part of a
wider program of Public Health reform
and you go on to note that HPS
colleagues yourself included advocated
throughout the reform period for
recognition of the importance of actions
to protect the public from outbreaks of
communicable disease and incidents
involving non-communicable environmental
hazards to Public Health why was HPS
required to advocate in that way
um I can offer you two potential answers
to that one which is a corporate one and
perhaps one on personal one well please
it's also from a corporate perspective I
think that what was important here was
that we were trying to
um
ensure that there was Health protection
I'm having its place at a table when the
key objectives that were then listed
were not immediately ones that jumped
out saying Health protection was at the
center of things
um we had
um a further discussion on an ongoing
basis about this and that Health
protection we were assured was at the
center of everything that we were doing
on a personal note and I can see that
yes that was important that we continued
to advocate for clinical and scientific
leadership
and for health protection and being
important because we were mindful of the
importance of instance outbreaks and
regrettably pandemics
is at one zero two nine nine zero
because moving forwards thank you very
much this is the 2015 review of Public
Health in Scotland
it
was
um as we can see strengthening the
function and refocusing action for a
healthier Scotland it had as its basis
can you provide a summary of this
document please we can see at the bottom
that although it's it's headed 2015 it
was actually
um
produced finally in February of 2016.
tell us what this is about please Dr
mcmenaman
so here I'm coming back to our Central
um rationale for what we were trying to
do
um it was important that we were trying
to put Health inequalities at the center
of everything that we were doing
you've heard I'm already testimony from
Bamber and marma about the stalling and
life expectancy as one indicator of the
health of the population
this was Anna cutting against this
backdrop where we were very aware of the
need to try and come together to address
those Health inequalities and hopefully
to then have an increase in the healthy
life expectancy of individuals
was there anything within this review
about the involvement of Public Health
in terms of Laboratories
yes this is and it's important I think
here there is a an important distinction
that I have to offer about what um you
mean already heard in testimony about
and for the health Protection Agency yes
or public health England and then the UK
email Security Agency unlike the
situation for all of those success or
organizations
um Public Health Scotland's rule in the
laboratory services management was in a
commissioning role only right so our
opportunity then to have
a a great effort and discourse about
that was certainly not something that
was
um addressed in the mean by this kind of
document
what role did HPS and and then later PHS
play in commissioning National
microbiological reference Laboratories
what role did it play
so right up until
the end of the time period for which we
are discussing this pre-pandemic yes
period our role was limited in the mean
to this commissioning role for the
national
um Laboratories that would be doing
reference work
that's unlike the situation then where
um much of the routine work might be
offered through either a combination of
oxal Laboratories in England and the NHS
service Laboratories
is it correct that the sponsors the the
Scottish government and the convention
of Scottish local authorities or kosler
were engaged in developing an annual
um operation plan for for PHS
yes and uh We've continued and it goes
beyond the team frame of the examination
today but we're certainly
um very much encouraged by the ongoing
work which is developed following one
from the beginning of the pandemic and
that we are currently involved in
um for some of the commissioning work
going beyond that into and what is the
needs assessment that we have for
laboratory services across all of
Scotland thank you
I'd like to ask you now
a provision of expert advice
to the Scottish and the and the K
government and the extent of hps's
involvement in scientific advisory
groups such as nerd tag and Sage
what was
the the role of the Scottish Public
Health Service in
the nerve tug Advisory Group
the member to start off with
um so
CH and I'm sure that you you've had
already quite a bit about this
um is
um
an organization which has been set up
which has taken
um through a robust appointment process
experts in individual areas it just so
happens that I was successful in
application to that on a personal basis
right rather than it being Public Health
Scotland which are represented as a type
of meter right okay and
were there other representatives from
other devolved Nations also present when
when you were there at its Inception
um and it's changed over time then it's
certainly been important to have an
opportunity for other colleagues to be
co-opted into that process and professor
and Peter Orby in the most recent past
day and has been instrumental in trying
to ensure that it depended upon
the setting that we're considering that
there's an appropriate scientific
representation
um across the whole of the country right
in terms of the subject matter that that
nerve tag considered during your time
there
do you have a view as to whether or not
that was more limited than it might have
been and if it was were there other
aspects that that you think as an
organization as an Advisory Group they
would have benefited from including in
in the in the matters that they
considered undiscussed
yeah I'm very much struck
um by uh
both the testimony that I've heard from
Witnesses here but also from looking at
the witness statements that have been
provided both by Wendy Barclay and by
um by Peter Orby yeah
they give a good account I think of that
there is always this balance a balance
about we have six questions that we're
trying to address because
um the government of the day have key
things that they would like us to
address
but that the scientific
um curiosity of many of these
individuals in the same room is
extraordinary
um that the the these experts are often
bringing complex issues that they have
noted and would be important for the
group to begin to consider and there's
opportunity and through that Network to
then encourage
um one or other of the administrations
or
um the Department of Health to then put
that down as a significant item for
discussion at next meeting yes you may
be aware of the evidence given earlier
today by Sir Chris Whitey on this
subject he landed on an arbitrary
percentage of 80 20 yes but um but but
that I think Accords with with the
evidence that you've just given that
there needs to be a two-way street which
is another phrase taken from some
absolutely I don't quite know what the
percentage is and that is an
epidemiologist that you'll probably get
a an hour and discourse from me about
that but yes I agree all right thank you
very much
we know from your witness statement that
you also sat on Sage representing HPS as
it then was PHS as it now is and
um tell us about your time there please
Dr mcmenaman and and whether you think
that there are improvements that can be
made in terms of the way that that
Advisory Group conducts itself
um my time as an observer and all of the
proceedings
um getting to as many of those as I
possible get along with many colleagues
was it was an extraordinary examination
and forensically at times of the
the key challenges presented of the day
um
those individuals who were coming who
were giving of their time freely and
where
truly incredible and I have nothing but
respect for everything that they were
able to see and do and my role um there
was limited perhaps if there were key
things that um we were providing either
as validation of observations that were
occurring
um South of the Border or in the other
Administrations
or for the first time being able to
present
um interesting observations particularly
in the early days of the estimation of
vaccine Effectiveness we were able to
see using the eve collaboration data
that had been set up as a consequence of
the hibernation projects and set up
after the swine flu pandemic and
important observations there about early
insight to what we might see in the
population an early light of a path
potentially out of the lockdowns and
social restrictions that we had in the
population
and whilst you were present at Sage
meetings where you convinced that there
were mechanisms in place to promote
Challenge and to ensure a range of views
as we've just discussed is is so
important in these advisory groups yeah
I think that
um all of the siege meetings were
equally led by in either of a supportive
elements or Chris with your others who
might be deputizing of a day
um there were great opportunities for
colleagues to be able to see
um without reservation what their own
views were about particular challenges
um and to challenge mindset about
um any key things that we're being
discussed
thank you a different topic now
I'd like to ask you about hps's status
as a category 2 responder under the
Civil contingencies Act of 2004.
and what is your view of it
being assessed as a category to
responder do you think there is Merit in
its categorization being raised to a
category 1 responder or do you foresee
difficulties if that were to happen
and if I may if we can present two um
things yes it was a corporate thing and
a personal thing from a corporate
perspective I can see that it is really
important that we have a category one
response labeling because we are at the
heart of the assessment of risk we are
um important in all of that and on a
personal basis I I I can't understand
why
um our organization
um should not be designated as as a
category one on the basis of the
guidance and response function that we
have in supporting major incidents and
pandemic
becoming a category 1 responder carries
with it additional responsibilities and
duties do you consider Dr mcmenaman that
public health Scotland is is able to
provide those and is the right
organization dealing with public health
to be able to carry out those additional
duties and responsibilities absolutely
with one caveat
and that is obviously resource
funding yeah
all right thank you
finally I'd like to take you through a
series of
um
scenario testing exercises and and to
ask your expert opinion on on what you
think worked well and and what might be
capable of being improved
there are some names here that the
inquiry has not yet heard about because
they are Scottish specific
one back in April of 2009 an exercise
called called crore
what was that all about Dr McManaman so
as you may imagine it would be something
to do with equal or uh the likes of um
of course that even influence and
influenza immediately yeah spring to
mind and of course that's exactly what
it was right about all right
um you note in your statement that the
plans for this exercise were in fact
overtaken by the swine flu pandemic and
although it was it was well planned the
the table tabletop exercise itself did
not take place was it rescheduled
was it was it rescheduled which sorry
called crore
yeah I think that it was not rescheduled
um particularly because we suddenly had
a natural event that was presenting not
too long afterwards
um with the Swain influenza and pandemic
so my understanding at least if my own
regulation or our fathers of the time
was that we had a natural challenge yes
it immediately formed do you know
whether any of the preparations for the
exercise were able to be drawn upon when
swine flu hit
and certainly much of the constant
evolution of thinking that we had
in any of our preparedness it was to
address
um many aspects of what were to be
covered and by that kind of exercise in
particular for the evening influenza
database that we had that ultimately
became what you want well I'm sure hear
more about
um in response to module 2 with the
first few 100s
approach that we had for Gathering
clear concise information about the
first cases of any new infection also
known as ff100 isn't it
um the next exercise on my list is
Castle Rock in September of 2010 I'm not
going to ask you about the details of
that because it simulated a chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
incident so far from the the topic of
this inquiry but but I would like to ask
you about the fact that this was an
exercise led by both the UK and Scottish
governments
do you have a view as to how well
um a a joint operation such as that and
we're going to come in a moment to talk
about exercise cygnus but how how
something created by
um
by governments in in two separate
nations are are capable of providing
um benefit to to both of those Nations
is that something that you would promote
or do you think that the Scottish only
exercises designed and focused as they
were on Scotland
um are are better in the long run well I
think the truth of that is that the
answer is I need both yeah we need to
have um that local exercise capability
to see what we can focus on what what
sometimes is forgotten is
um every exercise can only focus on a
few key things
um it can't necessarily Encompass
everything so having that opportunity to
focus on that local
um issue becomes really important
particularly for the local authorities
who might be dealing with that whereas
on a UK basis having an understanding
about
um how to relate to each of those
constituent parts of the UK and where we
will get key information from becomes
important and one important thing that I
should say about that is that and for
some aspects of environmental Public
Health and Scotland
um is entirely Reliant through a service
level agreement with the health
Protection Agency Public Health England
and the UK Health Security Agency and
that's reserved issues like
um radio nuclear issues ETC
oh thank you
Silver Swan took place over the latter
part of 2015 and its aim was to assess
the preparedness and response of
Scotland's local and National
arrangements for an influenza pandemic
over a prolonged period this
I'm going to describe it as a rather
successful exercise
focused on four areas Health and Social
care excess deaths business continuity
and overall strategic coordination
nationally but of importance you say in
your witness statement was what came out
of that exercise concerning PPE
tell us about that please Dr mcmenaman
so inevitably
um there are key things that come out of
every exercise you hope that you're
challenging perceptions
identifying issues and the expectation
that you'll be able to address them in
subsequent work
m part of our organization at the time
within Health protection Scotland was
our
antimicrobial resistance and Healthcare
Associated infection team and that's
short-handed to our high
um it's with
um much personal regret and corporately
and regret that we saw this part of our
organization didn't come with us into
public health Scotland it remained
within a National Services Scotland it
was however the most painless divorce
unsure of
um of medical and nursing teams because
we continued and continued to this day
to work very closely with our high
colleagues who were an essential part of
the pandemic response the reason why I'm
focusing on that is background first is
that it's this our high team who have
become pivotal to us in addressing
everything to do with personal
protection equipment and although I can
offer my own understanding of that from
representing public health school and
then HPS of the time
it might well be that a separate um
issue that you may wish to consider
asking over our colleagues Who Remain
within National Services Scotland the
question that you asked there was
what happened
um the key thing that we can see is that
there are issues of interpreting
um what the the safe use of personal
protection equipment should be within
the NHS
that becomes really important for us to
make sure that we can have all of that
sharing with the infection prevention
and control teams in any of their
hospital or taken taken to care settings
but also across the NHS estate
and that key learning was something that
continues
um to be part of our discussions on an
ongoing basis including what we do for
high consequence infectious disease and
there are eye colleagues are right and
up the middle of all of them
the fact that
the provision of PPE and the stockpiling
of it and the and the use of it across
the whole of the um health system in
Scotland had been raised in the latter
part of 2015. and
must have meant that by the time
operation exercise cygnus
um falling into that trap again sorry
exercise cygnus took part in October of
2016. that
that uh knowledge and and those concerns
could be carried forwards because you I
think personally uh attended exercise
cygnus did he not on behalf of um HPS
and we know that the aim of that
exercise was to assess preparedness and
response across the whole of the United
Kingdom for pandemic influenza and did
you in fact take to exercise cygnus the
information and the knowledge that that
you had gained through Silver Swan
yes indeed not just me but many of my
colleagues who were joining on behalf of
either Health protection Scotland or
other in parts of the NHS in Scotland
find a
size cygnus
huge undertaking wasn't it this inquiry
has heard that it involved 950
participants and as a matter of Interest
did you travel over to that or down to
England in order to attend or were you
attending remotely from from Scotland
how did it work I mean if that was
attending remotely I think for that
particular one and we know it took place
over the course of two days and that the
initial scenario was that the influenza
pandemic had had just hit and then the
the the further day was
um some some time beyond that once um
systems had had been up and running for
some time
um
when you came away from exercise cygnus
did you believe that public health in
Scotland was well prepared for the
outbreak of a pandemic influenza or did
you appreciate that there were
significant lessons that had been
learned and preparations that needed to
be put into place in order to to get
that level of preparation to an
acceptable degree I think the latter
um despite any great and work by any
number of very industrious colleagues
working in the backgrounds volunteer
included but yes that it continued to be
very significant things that we needed
to continue to work on what actions did
Public Health Scotland take away from
cygnus and are you able to tell us
whether or not but by using a couple of
examples those were carried through and
indeed were in place by the time the
pandemic hit
and earlier I spoke about that the
Scottish Health protection Network being
used as an important vehicle to make
sure that we and all of our colleagues
then were sharing
um our own experience in the learning
I think that the key thing that we were
then coming back to was and for personal
protection equipment as you've already
highlighted as an essential bit of what
we needed to do and our AI colleagues in
particular were very very focused on
this but also some other thinking then
about high consequence infectious
disease and what we should be doing
about that you may or may not know that
um Scotland does not have a high
consequence infectious disease unit we
rely then on and through service level
agreements and the the the excellent
service that's offered through
um colleagues in England where we then
have to transfer patients that might
require that high consequence of faces
disease management that's part of our
reignited discussion that we're having a
north of the Border currently about what
should be the case and the the new world
that we are living in where we are
learning as much as we can about
pandemic preparances for the future and
do you believe either personally or
corporately that
should have its own hcid system and I
think certain at the moment corporately
that we
um wish to see what the the balance is
and we understand that of course
um there should be value for money and
everything that we do is there a good
enough case in this instance that there
should be my own personal perspective is
that um I'll be influenced by um or
infectious disease clinicians you spoke
to just one of those early in the day
with Professor Chris Whitley
um South of the Border but it will be
important that we have
um a view expressed by all of those
colleagues about whether that would be
important to have that capability
locally or whether we continue to rely
on the
um the the good grace of our UK
colleagues to support us
thank you Dr mcmen would you excuse my
back please
foreign
thank you my lady I can confirm there
were no rule 10 requests in relation to
this witness and so that completes Dr
McMenamins evidence just one question
from the doctor um you mentioned in your
witness statement that you were doing a
Lessons Learned report it'd be available
by April 2023
was it available by April 2023. my lady
my apologies that my understanding is
that it was near and completion but it's
not yet completed I can certainly
um ask my colleagues in the background
and try and make that available as soon
as possible that would be really helpful
thank you very much indeed well thank
you I'm sorry we've kept you so long I
hope it hasn't done much up your
arrangements for returning home that's
tall
um very well we'll finish the today and
we I am sitting again at 10 30 on Monday
thank you my lady thank you all very
much indeed all rise